you
for committee members right now we have
uh several uh items we want to discuss
uh one on scheduling i do not have a
specific date on the first session yet
that we're going to have here in the
general court room that was you know we
know that we had cross or the date to re
get our early bills out that was the
17th has been backed over the 10th now
when that session day occurs it's still
worked out because the governor is going
to give his address and all that and try
to mesh the two together so that's why
there's you know it has been defined as
to exactly which day it's going to be
whether it's going to be a wednesday or
thursday i don't know and as soon as we
find that out also um the last week in
in the month of february is usually
school holiday week
we're going to try to have that as a
date in which this committee won't be
hearing anything or doing anything but
you know i can't say it definitively
until we know where we are on executing
some of the bills coming up
and to make sure that that that those
dates agree with what's going on
elsewhere outside of our realm here like
in the school districts and all that
i know up north the school vacation
dates always a little contrary to what
is south of
yeah and and of course we should really
be gearing all this around what we do in
the north country not what we do down
here in the southern part of the state
and and i would agree with that mr
chairman all right thank you you and i
are on the same page in that one
and you didn't you have to use your
principal voice that's thank you
um
uh the other point is that we've now
yesterday we did a great job in getting
some uh bills exact and out of the
committee here and we have a lot in
consent um the majority of all were went
on consent but i'll remind those they're
tasked with writing the committee report
or what we call used to call the blurb
please get that in immediately to me
you can send to my email address and
then what i'm going to do is put them
all in a folder and send them to
jennifer jennifer then works with people
upstairs
or to lindsay and then she works
upstairs and then they get across the
paul smith and then on to the speaker
for final approval
so we need to get those done because
we're going to start getting overwhelmed
with everything here we don't want to
play catch-up ball
so with that i'd also like to say on the
first bill here after it is introduced
here by the prime speaker we're then
going to call the department of
education up they have asked for a few
moments where they can speak on some of
the technical side of things in terms of
all these bills they're dealing with
today and we have the people in charge
that program here and so if you're
looking through the charter school bills
which we have on the docket today
feel free to ask the the department any
technical questions referencing any of
those bills at the very start here we
can get them
done with their business so they can you
know get on other things as well so mr
green and company are here so we'll do
that after we hear the prime sponsor on
the first bill here and it is hb 1074
relative to notice to a charter public
school of a special education services
meeting
welcome thank you mr chairman members of
the committee good morning for the
record my name is maureen
mooney a state representative from the
town of merrimack that's in hillsborough
district number 21.
i've provided written testimony to the
clerk or the vice chair this morning and
so hopefully that's been distributed to
all of you at this time
house bill 1074 of which i am the prime
sponsor and for the record i am in
support of
does two things
first of all it corrects a typo
believe it or not that exists in current
law in rsa 194 hyphen b
where the word charted
appears
instead of
char turd
second of all it inserts into law a
requirement
that chartered public schools be given
prior
notice
for subsequent meetings
of an iep
team
as current law reads now
when a child enrolls
in a chartered public school
that child's resident district shall
convene a meeting of the iep team
and invite
a representative of the chartered public
school
after this initial meeting
the law is silent as to subsequent
meetings of the iep
team
although subsequent invitations
may not be necessary going forward
chartered public schools do need prior
notice
so just to be clear here we're asking
for notice
not necessarily invitation
of subsequent meetings for successful
student achievement
communication and awareness are critical
for special education
with the courtesy of prior
notice
the chartered public school can better
track
monitor and communicate a child's iep
plan
it is not in the best interest of a
child if his or her chartered public
school is completely
unaware of subsequent iep team meetings
which could result
under current law
this bill is meant to strengthen the
special education programs for children
at chartered public schools with a
reasonable request
that the child's resident district
provide prior notice
of subsequent ie team iep
team meetings
now in concluding my introductory
remarks
i want to mention a couple of things
first of all this bill as well as others
i'll introduce today
are a series of bills that have
originated from the ground
up
right from those most familiar with the
operation
of a charter school
to this point here
not from top down
also i want to mention that throughout
the day in this room collectively
i believe will be close to about a
hundred years worth total if you do all
the math
of those involved and familiar with
charter school adding up their
experiences
with operating charter schools
administering them
founding them
being on boards
it goes on and on
charter school
experts and those most familiar on the
ground with the operation of a charter
school will be here today
and they have requested this bill
so with that
uh just to emphasize the importance
of this bill to special education
to also emphasize the origins of this
bill and others i'll introduce today
which is very important to hear from
those who know charter schools best
that will conclude my remarks
and i want to thank you all for your
attention
on this bill and others i'll introduce
this afternoon
thank you mr chairman thank you very
much representative are there questions
for the representative
yes representative cordelli
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative moody for being here um
the uh the child with disabilities who
was attending a charter school
might
well have an iep but also being
part of the regular education
program at the charter school would
would that be a correct statement yes
thank you i have one one question and
then perhaps we can get to the
department um you're saying prior notice
of subsequent meetings
is silent
in our our statutes
that is my reading is it silent in the
administrative rules
and in federal law
that would be a question for the
department
and those speaking
after me
however
my interest today my
motive to bring this bill forward is to
clarify it in the state statutes
thank you
further questions yes representative
nelson
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you emphasize invite
over
um a notice why would you do that
thank you for the question very good
question
because there's a big distinction
an invitation
which is in current law for that first
meeting means the chartered school team
is invited to attend that first meeting
but we're looking for
notice
thereafter not necessarily an invitation
and there could be reasons for that
it's possible a parent doesn't choose to
have the chartered school at the team
meeting
so there that thus they wouldn't want an
invitation we wouldn't want to force
that on the parents
so we're looking for the minimum of
notice
to be given to the chartered school with
all due respect to those that are on the
iep team including parents resident
district teachers etc
huge distinction and i'm glad you
brought that up so i could re-emphasize
that again today
well
thank you very much uh what i'd like to
do now is if there's no more questions
for the sponsor of the bill
i'd like to invite as i mentioned
earlier nate gree and green and company
that are with him regarding the
charter schools
as their
administered through the department of
education if we have questions for them
regarding this bill or
and perhaps what's coming up they'll be
around so we can follow up questions but
they're going to try to give a little
view of what how the charter schools
function
so
thank you for representing mooney and
we're going to invite up now nate green
thank you very much just give me a
moment i'm going to wipe this down per
uh good morning good morning the record
uh my name is dr nate green i am the
bureau administrator for the bureau of
educational opportunities with the
department of education
with me is tal bear tell works within my
bureau and is the administrator over the
office of chartered public schools
um we're here and as uh the chairman
mentioned we'll be here for a majority
of the day to provide technical
assistance across a variety of charter
school bills that are here today but i
want to turn it over to tal to just
provide a little bit of brief background
on the current charter school system
good morning
just uh real quick to give you a quick
summary currently we have 31 charter
schools across the state of new
hampshire
of those 31 28 are currently open
with three slated for opening and fall
of
in the pipeline for additional schools
we have 10 prospective schools that have
filed letters of intent
uh and they are all at different stages
of the process uh for charter
authorization
charter enrollment is currently at
5020 for this year which is
approximately a 10 increase over charter
i
say i would add
probably
regarding the charter school grant um
we have uh seven schools that
were awarded the charter school grant in
the first round which occurred in august
four of those were startups and then the
remaining three were replication and or
expansion
i know that several of the bills have
been proposed today are bills that make
small alterations or provide some
additional technical aspects to current
law already
some of this has helped to fix some of
the problems that we've seen within our
current charter school system
and we're happy to take any questions
that the committee has
yes representative cornell
thank you thank you for taking my
question i was just wondering do you
know how many students with within the
are students with disabilities or on an
iep
do you have the number for that
i don't have that information no not off
hand but we can provide that information
to the committee how many students this
this bill would affect as a percentage
sure total yeah we can get that
information okay thank you very much
further questions representative
woodpock
thank you chairman
good morning gentlemen uh thank you for
taking the question
you said there's about a 10 increase in
the charter school population this year
over last year can you give us a
ballpark what grade level that you saw
most of it in
i don't have a i don't have a breakdown
by grade level but i can certainly pull
that information thank you so much
further information
i had one question for and maybe you all
don't have that or maybe i should go to
special ed folks to do that but we on
this particular bill we've heard that it
is silent on uh how we address or notify
on subsequent iep meetings
is it is silent just in statute or is
there administrative rule which uh
explains the process
and that we have to follow in the
schools
uh i do know that uh becky is here from
the department from the bureau of
special education and so she should be
able to answer questions that are
specific to the federal part of the
special education law okay we'll hold
that question for becky then
are there other yes representative
mullen thank you mr chair and thank you
for uh taking my question
do you
receive complaints from parents in your
role
in my role i do not
okay so would either of you have any
sense of
how many families have raised this as an
issue
that's something that we can get
information on for the committee we do
have a particular individual at the
department that handles special
education related complaints
i'm not sure if they track whether the
student is a charter school or a
traditional public school uh in
particular but um we could take a look
and see if we have breakdowns of those
numbers
can i just follow yes thank you mr chair
and also um
is there anything there's i don't
believe there's anything in statute that
was would prevent a parent
from inviting a member of charter school
staff to attend a meeting at the home
district is that correct to my
understanding the parent is one that has
the ultimate control over iep meetings
uh who's attending the the makeup of
that meeting within what's allowed by
current federal regulation i will
obviously defer to becky on the exact
specifics of that but i do know that the
parent
ultimately has the most control when it
comes to the makeup of the iep team
thank you
thank you and we'll get rebecca up here
and do course
are there further questions
thank you very much and just hang loose
a little bit maybe i'll be back up there
sounds great thank you thank you
i'd like to invite uh next
jane bergeron from the new hampshire
association of special education
administrators
before that we do from them as a
technical support they are let's see
we'll put them right on
on becky's card
good morning everyone my name is jane
bergeron and i am the executive director
for the new hampshire association of
special education administrators
thank you for the opportunity to testify
before you this morning my comments will
be brief
as you will see in my testimony and as
you have already heard
and and no
the resident district is responsible for
all aspects of the special education
process
from referral to the funding to
conducting of all meetings which of
course includes the iep team meetings
as you all know that when a meeting is
held the law requires that in writing
that the iep team be
provided written notification 10 days
prior to the meeting and in my testimony
i've listed who the iep team
members need to be by law and that
includes
the special ed teacher the general ed
teacher
the parent
the lea rep as well as any other
individual that has knowledge or
expertise of the child
and so all of those folks get notice
of any iep team meeting
whether it's initial one or
uh subsequent greetings and our school
districts are responsible for notifying
those folks which includes the charter
school
um and um therefore we
feel as though this bill is really not
necessary it really duplicates something
that's already required in state and
federal law
uh so we find it to be unnecessary we're
here to oppose the bill and
uh would open it up to any questions the
other thing i would add is
we're not aware that this is is a
challenge and we would ask the question
what kind of data exists that would say
that there's been a pattern or trend
that would warrant some kind of new bill
and also would note that the department
of ed does monitor local school
districts on a regular basis when it
comes to special education
in a variety of ways and that includes
those students with ieps
enrolled in charter schools
so i would open it up to any questions
that you might have
thank you very much jane uh questions
yes representative lakers
yes thank you
i noticed that on the thing that you
handed out
it says additionally any other
individuals who have special knowledge
and expertise
can be invited
and i think
the bill is about making it
shall be notified so as opposed to just
well that and that's the language from
federal and state law um and you know
the parent can invite anyone that they
want and the general ed teacher
typically is the teacher at the charter
school
so they would naturally get an invite
because they are responsible for the
vast majority of the instruction for the
student
thank you
that's in rule
uh in law
uh further questions
nazi thank you very much thank you
i'd like to
have have next
kim lavalley
thank you mr chairman for the
opportunity to speak
my name is kim lavalley and my
background that brings me here to
testify on this is i've opened two
charter schools i'm a co-founder for two
new hampshire charter schools i'm
working on several other charter schools
and i also chair the new hampshire
charter school foundation which is a
non-profit with volunteers to support
charter schools in the charter
application writing or their startup to
help them avoid some of the challenges
that happen when you're doing a brand
new startup
i've also had two of my own boys
graduate from a charter school and one
had an iep
i speak in favor of this bill
we at charter schools i don't believe
it's intentional from the resident
districts but there are notices that do
not arrive for these meetings meetings
are being held the school is unaware
and it makes it challenging the thing
that we're trying to do is increase that
communication that dialogue that's what
will benefit the students if everybody
is talking on the same page we're all
doing the same thing for the student
it's going to benefit the child so we're
requesting
that this please
be changed
do you have any questions thank you are
there any questions yes representative
mullen and then
thank you mr chair and thank you so much
for joining us this morning and taking
my question
um in these situations where you've had
kids whose resident district has not
notified you of an iep team meeting
have um you reached out to those school
districts and what has the response been
to your
initiating
yes i believe all the charter schools
when this happens we reach out and it's
it's not intentional it's not
intentional i don't believe there's ill
will there um i think sometimes the
charter school is kind it's an
afterthought
so while the parents may have that
opportunity to invite us i don't think
we should put the burden of that on the
parents i think the schools should be
communicating
thank you for the question further
questions coming down represent cordelia
thank you thank you for being here um
we've heard testimony that
if the child with an iep is taking part
in regular education
at the charter school
federal law requires
notice
if the child is not in
the regular instruction program in the
charter school
is that when the problem arises or is it
um any time there there could be a
problem in receiving notice
i can speak for the regular ad and again
that's where i see it happen
notice is not arriving to the school
people find out about the meeting a week
later when paperwork arrives with
updates or something so
and again i don't think it's intentional
but i think putting it in writing is a
good step in the right direction
uh follow-up questions i have one for
you you've worked with the charter
schools you've had a youngster in a
charter school with an iep
when
when this
failure to get notice of an iep has
occurred has there been an effort on the
part of the charter school
or yourself to notify the department of
education that what is supposed to be
happening in accordance with federal law
and i believe our administrative rules
which have gone through our jail car
i have had conversations not to file
formal complaints again i don't think
it's intentional but just as a reminder
that you know it works better if
everybody's on the same page and
communicating as a mother i did
make some phone calls because
i had i had actually been left off of a
notice so um but it
you know it was an oversight it was
corrected
and
we reach out to the school directly
typically the resident district as a
reminder please don't forget us next
time we want to be a part of the team
thank you
further questions
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you for having me i'd like to
invite uh bob best
merrimack
we have a conscientious group today all
wiping it down and
on certain days we go through the whole
day and i don't ever see it wipe down
we'll see what it's like at three
o'clock yeah
good morning mr chair and thank you uh
members of the committee for the
opportunity to be here to talk about
this bill
um
as to wiping down the desk now that
there's been an example that's been set
and followed a few times there's no way
i could not do this i'll be sort of the
bad guy in the group so now we're all
committed to it
um
so let me introduce myself my name is
bob best i am from uh merrimack and i am
an attorney at sullivan hollis orange
badge on because i do do lobbying for
other entities but i'm not here lobbying
for anybody here today i'm speaking on
behalf of myself and my own experiences
on the board of two charter schools i
provide legal counsel to four or five
others
i've been involved in this issue quite a
lot
the idea of notice and what federal law
requires versus what this bill will do
is an important question to ask
i believe the language in federal law
says that these
the regular education teacher may be
invited
i don't know that it requires that that
person be invited they should be it
certainly is a member of the iep team
and it's critical for the person who's
spending the most time every day with a
student to be a part of that iep meeting
but they're frequently not invited
i don't i i share
miss lavalley's
view that it's not intentional that it's
an oversight what happens with charter
schools is that they're located in one
town and have a lot of students from
that town but then they bring in
students from up to 20 other towns
around them sometimes
and some of those districts around them
could be a little bit far and they have
one or two students total
and the frequency with which they have a
special ed student is less frequent and
it's just sort of not an open line of
communication that works very well
um but it is absolutely critical that
the charter school be a part of that for
the many reason i mentioned they're the
one that spends most time with the kiddo
uh
but also
as a parent my oldest son had an iep um
when you have a failure in an iep team
meeting
um you've scheduled it a month out so
school starts in september sometime in
the middle of october you have your
first iep meeting it's a very busy time
and if that meeting fails to have the
right people at it you say well i'd like
to have another meeting with all the
right people at it
they try to schedule it for mid-november
around thanksgiving and it gets
disrupted and sometimes it happens in
december or january and
by the time you get anything going half
the school year is gone
half the school year is gone
you're thrown off by at least a month
probably more like two if you've got to
try to reschedule an iep team meeting
knowing how busy the school districts
are
and it's also important to note that
what the bill asks here is such a tiny
courtesy
an email
there's a meeting scheduled on
january 6th at 10 am
for
bob best
son how difficult is that to do and if
it's the viewpoint of school districts
that it's already required to be done
well then what in the world would be a
reason to object to having it here in
state law
now what that does do is it does allow
our own state department of education to
be involved in it
finding solutions for ieps that go wrong
under federal law is a very complicated
thing for parents to navigate and it's
always the parent that's in the role to
do that they've got to ask for a hearing
they've got to make the complaint and
that sort of thing and even suggesting
that it's up to the parent to decide who
to invite to their team meeting boy
that's a bit of a stretch um
as a parent i wasn't on charter school
boards when my son was going through
high school
it's an anxious moment to go to an iep
team meeting you don't really know
what's going on the federal iep system
is byzantine it's complicated
you really don't know a lot you kind of
expect all the teachers to be there and
then when they're not you're confused
and somebody says well there was
somebody in a substitute we couldn't
find somebody so we gave you the science
teacher instead of the english teacher
but to expect the parent to sort of have
the wherewithal to
know that they're the one that's going
to be responsible for letting the
charter school know or making sure
they're invited well that's a lot to ask
and it's just it's just unnecessary why
not just have the people who are already
scheduling a meeting already sending out
notices to a whole bunch of people add
one email to the list that says
january 6 at 10 a.m come on over
it's all the testimony that i have i
hope that answers the questions it does
happen quite a lot i've been involved on
behalf of clients
that have had this issue with some of
the sending school districts
i know that i have had some letters on
behalf of clients that have been sent to
the state board about special ed issues
i don't recall off the top of my head
whether this particular one was among
them
um
i don't think that those letters uh for
the other whatever subjects they were
sent for um caused any particular
response or improvement
thank you
questions representative luna thank you
very much mr chair and thank you
attorney best for joining us uh this
morning um just um just to clarify
um
your i mean your testimony i think was
very helpful
the bill before us right now i don't
think has anything to do with addressing
scheduling
anomalies or um or notification of
parents it's specifically about
notification
to the to the charter uh school when an
iep meeting uh has been scheduled and i
was wondering
given you're certainly given your
familiarity with um uh with this area
of law when you take a look at 194 b
colon 11 roman 3 b
uh which is on
on our new in our new books is on page
594.
um it it
it's it's basically it's exactly what's
in the bill here when a child is
enrolled by a parent in a chartered
public school
um the local education agency of the
child's resident district shall convene
a meeting of the
individualized educational program team
and shall invite a representative of the
charter public school
to that meeting
in your interpretation
does
does that only apply to
the first meeting
of at the beginning when a child is
enrolled by a parent in a chartered
public school or does that first
sentence when a child is enrolled by a
parent in a chartered public school
apply to
the entire period of time the child is
enrolled by a parent in a chartered
public school that's a great question
and thank you for it um
your initial comment about the bill not
addressing scheduling anomalies though
um i want to just comment quickly on
that um when the charter school doesn't
get an invitation and isn't present the
iep team meeting isn't as productive and
has to and that's what creates the
anomaly that has to get rescheduled so
it does sort of create these anomalies
um i would have thought common sense and
courtesy would have resolved this kind
of a question easily enough or even just
a reminder once in a while
easily enough why wouldn't you want to
know from the teacher that is spending
the most time with the student what's
going on and what's going to change and
all of that
now the outcome of an iep team meeting
is that the iep may be amended and that
needs to be immediately known by the
people that are going to spend their
time with their kids
and so that's what the importance of it
is i would have loved to come here and
say that this bill is unnecessary that
this language that's in here that talks
about an invitation to the initial
meeting implies that everybody should be
invited to all the meetings
but unfortunately that's not the case
i don't know what the interpretation is
by the school districts i don't know
whether they've gotten some legal advice
that says to do one thing or another or
like
i i mentioned earlier and miss lavalley
had mentioned whether it's just simply
inadvertent
but it's important it's critical to the
student that the ipt meeting be there so
why don't we just close the loop on some
unclear language and reinforce it and
then at a minimum the charter school and
the parent has rsa 194 b11 3b to show to
the school district to say you should
have done this and you didn't do it
quick follow-up mr chair so um so no and
i i understand that and and uh
and i um uh you know i i question
whether or not putting another thing
into law that's already in law
somehow makes it stronger or more legal
than it or more required than it was
before but do you think maybe a
something um
like a technical advisory coming from
the department to um to school districts
might enter charter schools might um
help to maybe put a little bit more
light on um
on this than than maybe
injecting another sentence into law
that's
already there
that that's a great comment so as an
attorney i am um keenly aware of
redundancies and laws and how you wonder
why in the world do we need to do this
again when it's already somewhere else
um
wherever it is today it's not effective
now would a technical advisory work i
think it would for a while i think we
wouldn't immediately arrive to be on
everybody's attention span but
some technical advisories and technical
bulletins that come out of agencies
are around for you know years and years
and years sometimes decades before
they're updated and they're just not on
everybody's attention anymore because
they're not searchable there's not a
database they're not an rsa it's
somewhere on a website uh and you know
sometimes for some state agencies you
find things that look like they were
photocopied a dozen times over and
originally typed on a typewriter as a
technical bulletin and nobody even knows
what it means anymore that it exists and
so when you when you pull it out you
show it to somebody they say well you
know that's a different time in a
different circumstance and i'm not even
sure what that means and and that's one
of the reasons why for it to be
absolutely clear and it's really a
simple concept to make clear um in the
statute that's published everybody can
search it online doesn't get lost it
doesn't get forgotten over time
great thank you thank you very much
attorney best and mr chair i've got to
um excuse myself to be in a subcommittee
upstairs in commerce all right great
thank you thank you representative
porter
thank you mr chairman thank you sir for
taking my question having taught in an
elementary school for a long time
having many children who had ieps and i
was the classroom teacher
when the iep meeting is scheduled it
always created a
conflict in my classroom schedule
who's going to cover my class will it be
during my planning period will it be
during lunchtime is it before school is
it after school
if the teacher that provides
the most service to the kids can't be
present
does that mean that the meeting
has to be rescheduled
i have a follow-up on this too sure um i
think that the parents role in
determining the iep team's construct and
whether they were able to meet with the
correct number of people or the right
number of the right individuals makes
all the difference in in the world in
that
i don't think that it's a hard and fast
rule but i do sympathize with what
you're saying and um i didn't sort of uh
offer it as part of my introduction but
my wife is the special education
coordinator for the merrimack school
district for a couple of other
elementary schools and she arranges
those meetings and sends out all those
notices and does exactly what you're
talking about to find the substitutes
for the teachers to get there so i i
absolutely understand that circumstance
and how challenging it is so i have a
follow-up yes okay so if i'm a teacher
at a charter school that's um four or
five towns away
and an iep meeting is called
and i can't have anybody that's covering
my group of children for the time it
takes to get there attend the meeting
and come back could be half a day or
more
will that if this is in place this this
language is in place will that
invalidate the meeting will the meeting
need to be rescheduled
you you understand where i'm getting at
this if it's
not yet you know she's not right there
in the building she's 30 miles away um
on the other side of the mountain
how and she can't get there what what
happens then sure absolutely um you know
i think today when you have the iep
meeting without this change in law if
the parent thinks that the right people
weren't at the iep meeting the parent
can produ pursue that kind of remedy and
that's doesn't change by this bill in
any other way
but what this notice does in a positive
way is uh two things
even if the school teacher can't come
it's possible that they can provide
information provide an update provide
some communication make a phone call
send a report do that kind of thing or
if that's not possible to do or not
wanted by the parent or not necessary
for the team at least the school
district the charter school knows to be
alert to a potential change in an iep
even if i couldn't go to the meeting or
wasn't invited or the parent didn't want
me on the team at least i know to be on
the lookout that something might have
changed in the iep that i need to be
aware of as a part of the team so it
accomplishes a lot even if it doesn't
always guarantee every single person you
know has their bottom in a seat at the
iep meeting
thank you are there further questions
representative tanner
thank you for taking my question uh you
mentioned and i just want some uh
clarity you mentioned that you had
many uh i believe was the word you used
uh had to do many letters
uh and
complaints on iep meetings and i was
just wondering out of that many
how many are specific were were you
talking just specifically charters
or were you including the other iep
uh complaints to the regular school
district sure absolutely um let me
clarify that as best i can um i have
represented charter schools and had this
issue come up many times the actual
letters that i've written to charter
schools are not it's a handful it's a
the letters to the department are a
couple
it's not
many times that i've you know complained
to the department but the issue comes up
uh quite a lot um and also i i maybe
it's helpful for um the discussion and a
question that came up earlier is sort of
what percentage of charter school
students are on ieps
and it varies from each charter school
to charter school but it usually sits
somewhere in that 10 to 20 percent range
sometimes as high as 25 of the students
have ieps
so it's a lot it's a
follow up on good
could you quantify just a little bit
more than many or several um
like in a given let's say last year
how many how many complaints
you had yeah sure so in one charter
school in particular i can recall um
there were at least two or three school
districts that each had between one and
three students for this charter school
where notices weren't provided for you
know the whole book if it happens for
one it sort of happens kind of across
the board because the communication link
is somehow broken down
so for example if if a charter school
has a relationship with town a that has
three students in them
they'll miss the notice on all three
students
for that so um
you know could i tell you that overall
through the whole state it's 25 or 28 or
whatever no i don't really have that
kind of data available to me
at the same time
for very for such a simple fix one is
kind of too many isn't it
thank you
thank you very much uh
yes representative nelson
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
it was mentioned earlier that if a
parent decides who they want at the
meeting
say i'm going to give you an example
uh there's somebody i'm a former special
ed teacher and i believe
that a student the parent wants an aid
for the student
i as a teacher
special ed teacher feel that that's
not right they don't need the aid you're
only enabling them
can the parent eliminate me so i can't
give
my opinion oh gee i don't know um i
don't
think they
can
necessarily stop the opinion coming
forward by saying you can't come to the
meeting but honestly i've never had to
address that question
and this was a little bit implied in
representative tanner's question as well
i don't do general uh special ed
representation for school districts in
in traditional public schools i don't
represent parents and and do that work
regularly my work is
exclusively on the charter school side
and representing the schools so um i've
never had to cross that bridge i don't
know the answer
if we have some specific questions that
are relative to the department because
they're the next ones up here
maybe we can hold those questions
represent whitcock can you hold that for
rebecca
yes representative mullen thank you mr
chair and thank you uh attorney bess for
taking my question
so in the uh situations in which you've
had the school district that has not
been providing notice
of the iep meeting and you've gotten
involved
what has the outcome
of those situations been
um
usually those situations have had uh
other faults as well which were greater
than the lack of notice um the school
district not um contracting to provide
the services that are in the iep with
either the charter school or anybody
else um and or or um huge gaps in the
scheduling sometimes students haven't
gotten their their special ed services
started until you know october or
november at the beginning of a school
year um and so although you reach out to
the school district and you try to
improve things and
for the moment you might get a little
bit of a response that one particular
issue has never sort of existed on its
own
where it becomes kind of the center of
the discussion that one is sort of the
small potato and in the big scheme of
things so it tends to just get
almost it's sort of a
by the way don't forget to give me
notice and that's kind of as far as you
discuss that um
so
i can't say that uh
i could give you a clean sense on
if we ask them for a we get b you know
what that's about so thank you very much
uh with that i think we're going to
thank you for giving testimony today and
we're going to invite rebecca fradette
from the department of education
uh who is in charge of that special ed
program thank you thank you for the
chance to be here and i appreciate all
the questions i'm sorry that that pushed
me behind over the couple of minutes
that i was actually hoping that that's
good morning good morning chairman ladd
thank you for allowing me to speak today
my name is rebecca ferdet i'm the state
director of special education at the
department of education um i first want
to provide some background information
on how special education works in
charter schools in new hampshire we have
a very unique situation for most
for the only state in the union that
runs our charter schools the way that we
do
our charter schools are not in special
education are not their own lea
the lea responsibility remains with the
resident district and that is why we're
in this situation of cooperation between
the resident district and the charter
schools every law that we have and every
law that is within idea bases the
relationship for this process on the
relationship between the lea and the
parent and so everything that
we discuss relates to how the lea works
with the parent to come to these
agreements
the relationship is not with the charter
school
the way the laws are written um not that
they should not be involved they should
be involved but if we are just looking
at the basis of the law everything is
written to go between the lea and the
parent so that's where
i will speak from because that's it kind
of gives you a grounding of where we are
for an iep team meeting we follow
federal law and it's in our rules under
1103 and it gives you who the iep
participation members are and any member
of that team needs to be a person who is
knowledgeable of the student so if
you're inviting people to the meeting
you might not necessarily invite
the head of the charter school they may
not be knowledgeable of that student and
that student's needs but you should be
inviting the regular education teacher
who provides services to that student in
the charter school and the regular
education teacher is a required member
of that team so that that is one of the
listed people within the within it
um
i'm just looking at my notes because i
took notes as we were going along so i
could address this one of the other
pieces that may cause confusion with
this bill is that if we're using the
terms prior notice written prior notice
is actually a defined term in idea and
that is the notice that the lea gives to
the parent to say what action they are
proposing or refusing to provide for the
student so if we then use that language
over here where we are providing prior
notice to a charter school i believe
there's going to be confusion as to what
a prior notice is if you're we it's
clearly defined in in ida it has been an
idea for
the entire time ida has been alive so
and we provide trainings on what written
prior notices this would deviate from
what that definition says for written
prior notice
the act the charter school should be
invited the charter school participants
that are listed should be invited to
that meeting and they should be
receiving notice as the regular
i think
and then um
in regards to the memos and the
technical assistance that representative
tanner had done we follow one of the
office of special education programs
practices with the federal government
where they put out memos or technical
assistance
and they provide fact sheets that we are
able to look up on their website we
follow that same practice so
um
there are fact sheets that are on our
website there are what we call memos
that have information that clarify
practices we refer to them frequently
when working with the fields if there
has been something that we've needed to
clarify it is something that we refer to
on the website and say you can find it
here we will send people the link
i know that natasha lupiani who works
with many districts and parents will
also refer to many of those members to
provide that technical assistance that
may be needed to clarify some of those
rules and that's a practice that we have
taken from osep
and i would be happy to answer any
questions that you make so i have one
question and then we'll go
represent bowman others on the committee
so you say the um
the lea
should be sending notice to these
charter schools
obviously if it's going to be held at
the charter school you're going to have
to you know a schedule and a space
available in a time that's appropriate
um has your office or any office over
the department
received the concerns that
we are not being invited to the iep or
the
subsequent i i i'm looking at subsequent
ieps i see all ieps as an iep
and so it shouldn't be a subsequent ip
it's an iep meeting whether it's the
first year annual or every three years
you're in in the neighborhood of doing
that but i i'm really concerned that
if um
i would say
it's my guess but i know of several
districts where i live they are doing
this
um so then um
maybe it's a best practice i don't know
but i thought it was law and rule
what action has the department taken if
you hear is there uh communication
trying to clarify the law with the
directors of these lease a special edge
is there a corrective or improvement a
letter sent out saying you need to get
on and do this thing correctly
what's a doe doing sure so um we have
gotten probably in the two years that
i've been in my position maybe three or
four phone calls regarding um not
receiving notification on the part of
the charter school what we would do
because i will go back to again the
relationship is between the lea and the
parent so a charter school cannot file a
complaint with us regarding something
that the lea has not done the parent can
file a plan but the charter school
cannot
so but we would
reach out to the district and remind
them of their responsibility to invite
the members of the team that are
appropriate which would be the regular
education teacher at the charter school
and would clarify that role for them
they have no obligation to invite other
members of the charter school because as
i stated it's only members who have a
knowledge of the student at unique to
the student and would be able to
contribute to the meeting so while the
regular education teacher would be
somebody that they're required to invite
the principal or head of the charter
school would not be somebody that
they're required to invite
and i've just one follow-up question
uh when i was a school principal for all
those years and we had these iep
meetings we would get substitutes for
the teacher that had come into the
meeting or teachers plural
being is the lea responsible for
providing the
funds for a substitute at the charter
quick okay it's going around represent
boom then rep santana and then what
thank you mr chairman uh and i've been
holding this question
uh in the case of a charter high school
which we have a few
who is the general education teacher
that's going to be invited or all of
them
so typically what would be done in a
public school is that you would invite
all of them but typically you would get
one of them so that would be the same
case of all the teachers that they have
at the charter public school you may
invite all of them but one usually it's
i'm not able to can you and then they
figure out of those or
where does their disability impact the
most within the classes that they are
taking if they have a
specific learning disability in reading
you might want to make ensure that the
english teachers is the one that's
invited rather than the science teacher
but there's no requirement to say that
all of those teachers would need to be
at the meeting
that same issue occurs at the elementary
schools as well middle school represent
tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
uh the previous speaker mentioned that
this bill allows our own
new hampshire department of education to
get involved and i was just wondering if
that
if that is
how you see this bill that this bill
allows the new hampshire department of
education to become more involved
in these notifications of iap um
then currently exists under
our own statutes and federal ida laws
sure so um
our involvement may change slightly from
what it is because we would be reaching
out and saying you are required to
provide
notice to someone at the charter school
but again we go back to the relationship
is between the lea and the parents so
there would be no
there would be no way for a charter
school to file a complaint if they did
not receive notice it would have to fall
upon the parent to again file that
complaint to say the charter school was
not invited to my meeting
so we may provide technical assistance
like we do now and change the way we
word what we're saying but it really
wouldn't change
our ability to do anything different if
and just to make clear in my own mind so
this bill doesn't
uh
make it
any different with the charter school
either does it as far as whether they
can
they can they're involved or not it's
still the lea yeah okay thank you
represent woodcock
thank you representative i appreciate
your consideration i have a couple as
i've been waiting um just off the top
and you may assume you have the answer
do you know how many uh
charter schools uh are high school
focused
i i do not i could give you special ed
do we know that representative how many
actual child schools have high school
components
i i don't know but you know i would
imagine that there's a number of kids
there that go from middle school into
that level so i that we can get that
information i'm sure that we can get it
from d.o.e so but back to my original
question thank you um
thank you for taking my question um
in the la or as we read it and
i just want to make sure my assumptions
are correct
uh on line five which it doesn't matter
if you don't have that it just says they
shall invite and the initial didn't say
initial meaning it says shall invite the
representative um so my assumption is
that if i get an invitation it's an
invitation to participate
uh but the law and the second one it
says all subsequent meetings the as you
said there's no relationship with the
active violation actually got a
relationship with each other but it says
that they'll just provide a notice
so i'm assuming that a notice
is different from
a invite to participate if i were to
look at the wording because of the
definition of written prior notice i
would say that it is something different
um however if if
we wanted to have them noticed of the
meeting they could the charter school
representatives beyond the regular
education teacher
could be listed as an other participant
as appropriate so you you have these
required members that are typically
listed on your
meeting notice your regular education
teacher your special education and then
you also can say um we're also going to
notify
sally who has been providing some speech
path speech services but she may not be
able to make it but the speech
pathologist is here so they could be
listed as somebody else who is an other
participant but may not necessarily be
at the meeting but any participant has
to have knowledge of the child to be
participating in the meeting
okay thank you just so clarity then so
you're saying then that if i receive
this if the charter school receives the
notice
either in this case maybe visa to be the
parent but to receive the notice
that means in your mind that's the same
as an invitation to participate
it's not just that after the fact we're
having a meeting in two weeks on on
student x we're saying we're saying
that's the notice so what we're saying
now is you're you're welcome to send a
representative and participate right if
they were yes if they it would be an
option to participate it wouldn't be a
requirement to participate but if you
added them to the meeting notice it
would give them that notice of we're
having this meeting but it wouldn't
require them if you listed them as as a
separate member
thank you thank you appreciate it thank
you very much representative porter
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question i'm not sure you can answer
but you mentioned at the very beginning
of your testimony that new hampshire is
unique in how we handle special
education and charter schools um
can you give me an example of how other
states what they do with this sure so
most other states will um make
their charter schools their own lea and
then the then that charter school is
responsible for the special the
provision of special education services
so the charter school would be
responsible for funding that as well yes
and do they get funding from the state
to help them out yes or is it a tuition
that they check
they get they get it from the state to
help them out but many of those states
have income tax or have other means to
um be able to provide for those for
those pieces thank you
i wonder if one of
one of the aspects of this problem might
be addressed if we inserted the word
timely in front of notification industry
and when we're all talking about to give
the sense that time is of the essence
yep so for a notification for a meeting
we must provide 10 days notice so that
is already within the language um if you
if if a if a charter school needed more
than 10 days notice it would be
something else we would have to add in
but currently any of those
those notices for meetings is a 10-day
requirement from the date of the meeting
and typically a district provides more
than 10 days they may provide 30 days or
and some of them are reaching out to
parents and trying to find that day that
works and it might be three weeks from
now rather than 10 days from now so
thank you very much are there further
questions that's yes representative
nelson
thank you mr chairman thank you i'm a
little bit off but does the
parent have a right not to have somebody
come the school district wants somebody
to come to the meeting
and the parent says i do not want them
who's right
so if it's one of the required members
they would not be able to say like if it
were the classroom teacher or the
special education teacher we have to
have that at the meeting um if it were
somebody else um that does not have
knowledge of the child and has no is not
going to provide any information to the
meeting that's um supportive then yes
they could say they don't want the
person
yes
if it was another teacher in the school
not the classroom teacher would there
would they be counted as somebody that
could come or would the parents have
veto power if the if the teacher
works with the student and has knowledge
of the child they could participate in
the meeting
thank you very much uh there is no
this is one quick one thank you thank
thank you please thank you based on your
information and this information you
just gave us about notice and the ide
definitions right and the pro the tech
the process you currently use
the way this bill is awarded do you see
it as redundant and necessary
unnecessary or do you see it as
necessary
i think that there's obviously a concern
if this has been brought to this level
where we need to discuss this um but i'm
not i
i had expressed my concern about using
the language of prior notice um i think
that
if
i think that there is the requirement
for a regular education student who is a
member of the charter not student excuse
me regular the regular education teacher
who is a member of the charter school to
be invited to that meeting i think that
that clarifies that and maybe some
technical assistance might be needed but
i'm not sure that changing the language
would necessarily change the outcome
okay
thank you very much thank you
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you rebecca
for taking my question has there been
any discussion at the doe about
providing technical assistance to
leas and or charters about how to make
this happen
um no but they will be
that was going to be my follow-up
question so thank you for jumping right
thank you very much i think that's an
excellent point
further questions
thank you very much
and we have no more cards on that
particular bill so we're going to close
and go into the next
mr chair
yes
um as of this morning
four people supporting this bill seven
opposing and zero neutral thank you very
much
the gatekeeper representative porter and
i appreciate her doing that for us
okay going on down to the next one it's
hb 1141
and relative to special education
services for children in charter public
schools i'd like i'd like to welcome
representative cordelli
thank you mr chairman and uh honorable
colleagues uh for the record i am state
representative glenn cordelli
representing tuftonboro moultonborough
and sandwich in the beautiful lakes
region
hb
1141 is a resubmission
of a bill
1636 from 2020.
legislative services will tell you that
there is no such thing
as a placeholder bill
but this is a placeholder bill
i submitted this as a vehicle for
amendment
after work
was completed
at the end of
october
by the
study committee for house bill 581 in
relation to special education
i have an amendment
which replaces the entire bill
um
it also modifies some sections of the
2020 bill but
the amendment um addresses uh many of
well
several of the concerns that we heard
and i have copies of the amendment
um
and uh would be uh
available to talk about that at any time
thank you very much for your test my
other questions representative porter
thank you i just want a clarification mr
if the amendment is introduced
and it's changing the entire bill
is there an opportunity for the public
to comment and justify or
is this the only opportunity that the
public would have to discuss this bill
well if the amendment changes the whole
nature of the bill um
and the title and germaness yes we would
have another hearing
i have not seen that amendment so i
can't tell you uh
what's what's in it and so i can't make
that decision but a bill that totally
changes and goes to a you know a
different statutory reference uh
his title
obviously it's going from nuts to bolts
then we would have a hearing
if if i might mr chairman
it does change the title
and
replaces everything after the enacting
clause
okay so the chances are we may we may we
could uh we i'd have to read it i can't
you know but that it's not an early bill
so there's lots of time to
do that
yes represent tanner um is there any
reason we're not seeing that right now
if they're if it's available i think he
was just saying there is and then he's
giving us information he did not go into
any specifics about that amendment
knowing that he's been advised we've all
been advised not to do that
um
uh and uh so it will be made available
to us and we'll we'll
like like i just said represent porter
we'll look at it and see where we go
next
uh mr chairman um
when we finish uh should i hand out
copies of that amendment to the
committee yeah the amendment of course
will be introduced by this committee at
another time it's just information being
provided to us so yes uh there's no harm
and information coming to us
rather than waiting for an executive
session oh by the way i've got this
amendment i think it's wise to do it now
yes represent woodcock so for clarity uh
representative codelli
the amendment we may see in a few
minutes we can't talk about today but
we'll talk about the future
uh is going to totally uh change this
correct so we're probably not valuable
to waste our time discussing this would
you say that correct
thank you do you agree with that
representative well i i i believe we
have a bill in front of us right now and
there may be those i haven't looked to
see what we got for pink cards it looks
like there's some there
um so we have in front of us not that
amendment we have this bill so we'll
continue having the hearing on this bill
but we won't be discussing that
amendment at all thank you
representative porter
thank you mr chair and this does i think
fall under the purview of the bill we're
looking at and it's something that i've
wondered about um and perhaps uh
representative cordelli can answer my
question on if at an iep meeting it is
determined that a
youngster who's going to a charter
school needs a one-on-one assistance
in the classroom
who under under the current law or under
your bill
who is responsible for hiring that
assistant who is responsible for paying
that assistant who is responsible for
this for the uh
benefits allotted to that assistant and
who would be responsible for firing that
assistant if there was
a problem
uh thank you for the question um
i um
my
understanding is that the resident
school district is responsible for
services for that child in the charter
school and therefore would be
responsible for the
for the aid
go ahead
oftentimes in a public school the
one-on-one assistants
will take other responsibilities on when
she's not or he's not with the child
that needs her assistance right away so
in other words a lot of
the
paraprofessionals that were in my school
would be with their child when they
needed to be with them in the classroom
but when that child did not need them
that para would go and do a lunch duty
or a recess duty or go to the library
and watch the kids while the teacher had
a break
that sort of thing
would the paraprofessional that this
sending district is paying for
um be doing those kinds of roles at the
charter school do you
suppose
um
can i say
please i don't want to suppose a little
bit here but the lea is totally
that which is the sending the district
where the special ed person you know is
coming from
paris coming from
i i do think i'm sorry i i do think it
speaks to the relationship between the
resident district and the charter school
and the communication that is required
management of personnel supervision
first all that comes into play
uh further uh a discussion from yes
representative mullen
thank you mr chair and welcome back
representative cordelli
so as i read through this bill
i kept writing
isn't this already law
and i wrote that with regards to the lea
being responsible for services the
written consent
the uh
least restrictive environment and the
involvement of parents as full team
members i wrote isn't this already law
next to each one of those things so
i guess my question is isn't this
already law
uh thank you for the question
um
the bill in 2020 was
introduced
because of
discussions i had with
parents or maybe they had with me
in relation to problems they encountered
with having their special needs child at
a charter school
and break down
in various
areas of that
provision of services
so that's why i introduced the bill and
tried
not to dictate any one thing in terms of
where the services were to be provided
or anything like that but keep it
general um just to provide some
direction
for
in particular the parents so they knew
also
special ed
law is quite complicated as we have
heard
and based on the questioning
by this committee whenever there is
something of a
bill
with relation to special education so i
was trying to keep it generic but
provide some direction especially for
the parents as to
how that relationship should work
within the charter school resident
go ahead
so for my own clarity representative
i
i hear you and i think we've heard that
there are problems and people are trying
to solve them in a variety of different
ways but my question is the points that
are raised in the bill are they not
already part of fate of federal and
state special education law
representative
yes one of the emails we got on this
bill
from a charter school
person
was wondering about the shall be full
participants on you know that the
parents
shall be full participants on the iep
team
and their question was
what if
the parents don't want to participate
in this currently they can still go
ahead and have currently they do
in the lea go ahead and and have a
meeting just without the parents so that
the kid can get
whatever help they need
and with this by saying full
participants
it seems to imply that the parents would
have to be there and what if the parents
aren't willing
um i i think that that is uh
addressed in in federal law
in that
as you said
there are provisions in law for a parent
not being at a meeting and there are
requirements as to what happens
when that situation
if the parent doesn't show up there has
to be documented all the attempts
to
contact that parent for instance so i
think that there are provisions to
address that in law that i didn't
feel necessary to go into in this
thank you
thank you very much uh not seeing any
further hands right here for the
representative thank you very much
representative cordelli
we
we've already heard from the
department
and then we also have jane bergeron from
the new hampshire association school of
administrators welcome jane
again
represent cornell
thank you
this isn't even the bill we're going to
be discussing though when it comes time
to it's
that's that's debatable that the
amendment's not even on the table we'd
have probably a different hearing if
it's totally changed
so we have a bill in front of us okay
and we own that bill now okay and so we
have the courtesy of providing all that
input
thank you thank you very much welcome
thank you very much my name is jane
bergeron and i'm the executive director
of the new hampshire association of
special education administrators i won't
take a lot of your time i'm here to
represent over 270 members within our
association when we are in
opposition of the bill um and i'm
providing you with my testimony but much
of it you've already heard this morning
as you know the resident school district
is responsible for the provision of a
fape for all students with
disabilities that includes those who are
enrolled in new hampshire's public
charter schools we feel as though this
bill as written is
duplicative of what is already required
of school districts in regards to
providing a fape um as well as
um as mentioned the issue of parental
consent um which is required and
necessary that the parent be a part of
all aspects of the child's iep
development and the process and what
again raised the question
has there been
any kinds of identification of
non-compliance around the lack of
provision of faith for children students
who are
enrolled in public charter schools and
that
ieps are being amended without the
consent of
parents it's not something that um
we're aware of it's not something that
the department of ed has made us aware
of and we check with them regularly in
terms of things that we should be aware
of and uh working with our charter
schools to change
so i would take any questions that you
might have thank you very much are there
questions of jane bergeron
nazi thank you very much thank you
do we have any other cards on this one
that's jane
does the department have anything to add
are there any questions yes we do have a
yeah she's got one in
okay thank you very much for visiting us
again
uh represent woodcock thank you um
representative mull and i had similar
questions uh we just had to highlight a
different one of 101 a pencil
the the lara that's
proposed here you have a copy of that
yes i do okay so i'm looking at the
section of
line 13 and the particular section line
9-23 9-23 which addresses
the question of parental consent and
parental participation
so
can you tell me if those two attributes
of this law are currently in effect in
new hampshire
yes they are they are okay okay follow
up yes so based on the information
probably presided and the attempt to
change
is it your position or what is your
position is if is this bill necessary or
is it redundant
um anything that is within the bill
currently is something that is already
currently within law um
it may need clarification obviously
there's some concerns but it is already
currently in law
so
your position is it's necessary it's
redundant
i don't take it i i'm neutral she she
does not take a position on her pink
card
the department's here for neutral
oh i get the information thank you
you're welcome you read between the
lines and uh figure that one out i have
one question for the department and it'd
be a quick one
a number number of years ago the
representative sitting right directly
behind you to your left and i sat on a
committee over at the school boards
association in that building dealing
with special ed services to charter
schools
and that went on for numerous meetings
least restrictive environment was always
a hot topic
especially with charter schools
least restrictive environment can be
interpreted
you're going to serve me in my school
at which would be the charter school and
of course statutory losses no we don't
have to do that we can have that service
delivered back in the sending or in the
lea
have you had any issues with least
restrictive environments
language being used with charter schools
or
everything seem copacetic so for charter
schools because they are not an lea we
do not currently approve special
education programs within
charter schools
so anything that is provided within a
charter school is considered regular
education if you needed a special
education environment you would need to
go back to the public school to obtain
services within a special education
environment unless
somebody is sent to the charter school
to provide those services but a charter
school does not have any special
education programs per se so they would
not have any i understand so i don't
think you're really hitting on what i'm
asking
a child needs speech pathology
and there's a similar class back in
where that individual comes from whether
maybe four or five kids can get together
and this youngster over there would
benefit from that group however there's
also the opportunity to send a speech
pathologist to the charter school which
does happen
are we
encountering any issues with how we're
interpreting least restrictive
environment
so least restrictive environment only
applies to those programs that i had
discussed
as to the issue that you're addressing
um we are i know that there are issues
with staffing and so there are many
times currently that they cannot get
somebody out to the charter to school to
provide a service and then they would
need to have the child come to the
public school the regular public school
to get those services
but that wouldn't relate as we calculate
lre that wouldn't be within our
calculation of lre
am i making sense that is that clear or
l our least restrictive environment i'm
sorry
i understand least restrictive
environment and you know i dealt with
that um
thank you for your information that it's
a hot topic i don't think we're gonna
resolution here today on that
uh further discussion from the committee
yes represent lakas
um
following on a previous question
when you say that it's in law is it in
state law or federal law or
where both its different parts are in
different i mean i could
kind of quote all of them for you if you
wanted to but it's they're all in
thank you very much uh i don't yes
let's have a question are there rulings
by um federal government like ocr
or by the courts defining
um uh
addressing this issue about least
restrictive environment in charter
schools
so we go back to the
new hampshire is what osep referred to
as a unicorn in how we
address charter schools so we
do not address charter schools the same
way lre is calculated the same way in
other states for charter schools because
they are the lea responsible for special
education because we do not have the
charter school as an lea for special
education we can't calculate lre in the
charter school
it's based off of approved programs
within the state
and are we the only state that does not
recognize the charter school as an lea
yes
as i understand it yes
thank you very much i don't see any
further hands
and i don't see any other pink cards for
this particular bill so we're going to
mr chair yes at this time eight in
support
okay we're going to enter into
relative to charter public school fees
welcome representative cordelli
thank you mr chairman and colleagues
for the record
state representative glenn cordelli
representing tuftonboro moultonborough
and sandwich in the beautiful lakes
region
i have worked with the department and uh
actually the two gentlemen from the
department behind me
um on this legislation
which is based on uh
some complaints the department had
received um in relation to um
what was going on in a few charter
schools
um and i want to emphasize that these
are not
broad complaints
um but targeted complaints about a few
things a few issues that are going on
first
beginning online
two
there was an issue with fees being
charged by charter schools over and
above
the tuition provided to the charter
school
by the state
so
we've added the language that
any
fee charge this student shall not be a
condition for enrollment
there was some
that the fees were making it
difficult for the parent
to afford to go to the charter school
even
so that's why we
thought it necessary to put this in
statute
the second it's a new subparagraph of
getting on line 5
addresses
really border
charter schools
where they
can and do enroll
out of state
students
into the charter school
and actually can charge tuition
to those out of state
students
and
there was an issue about whether
the
state
enrollment for a charter school
what happens if they're accepting
out of state charter schools students
who are paying tuition
and that's crowding out basically
resident new hampshire students from
enrolling in that charter school
so that was the
reason for this new sub-paragraph
and
excuse me specifying that preference in
enrollment should be given to in-state
students to try and address
that situation
and again these are
uh not broad-based issues that are
happening within our charter school
community but more isolated
incidents but we felt uh that they
needed to be addressed for the benefit
of
new hampshire parents
and students are there any questions of
representative representative ellison
thank you mr chair thanks for taking my
question
can you give us some examples of
those non-application fees that were
being charged that people
contacted you about
um they contacted the department um and
um i do not recall in my conversations
with the department whether any specific
dollar amounts
were discussed but just that
some felt it was
a barrier in terms of attending that
school
thank you
are there further questions
yes representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative um for taking this
question when my husband and i ran our
little school
one of the
extras that we offered to the kids was
piano lessons we had a woman who came in
and taught kinder keys and it was a
wonderful program and they enjoyed it
very much but it was also a little bit
pricey
so
in order to keep our rates down we
charged the parents
a fee for
having their kids take the piano lessons
is that the kind of
fee that you're talking about here or is
it some other kind of fee i mean are the
fees that are being charged are they for
extras
or add-ons or are they part of the
regular uh curriculum i i think that
that might be better addressed to the
department um as they had
discussions with the uh the parents
involved
further questions
not
represent whitaker thank you just thank
sentence on watching non-application
fees
when you're talking about the term
enrollment it's not as a condition of
enrollment
is
that
is that enrollment are you talking about
not as a condition of acceptance
or as a condition of maintaining
enrollment
i i believe that um the issue was fees
that were expected when the child um was
applying to enroll in that charter
school okay so that the application
wrong right okay application fees
okay thank you
welcome any further questions of
representative cordelli
not seeing any hands thank you very much
do we have any other bills on
i don't want to draw this out but could
we get some clarification from the
department about what kind of fees we're
talking about here because there seems
to be some confusion about what
what fees were sure dealing with is
there anybody in the department that
could you you must have heard what
representative ellison was addressing
that might have some pearls of wisdom
hey green new hampshire department of
education i'll try to provide some
pearls of wisdom for you
we do have a number of parent complaints
we've received over the past couple of
years in regards to this issue
it is
both
fees that are charged as a condition of
enrolling in this school
that may be
not you know titled an application fee
but are as such and then there are fees
that are ongoing that as the student
comes back each year there are fees that
are expected as part of returning to the
school
which we would look at is going beyond
an application fee for the most part
these fees tend to be listed under the
category of things like supplies and
curriculum materials
so it's money that's being provided to
the school so that they can then provide
art classes textbooks and supplies for
carrying out the educational curriculum
at the school
we've seen some of these highs
some of these fees be as high as a
thousand dollars
okay
thank you
thank you represent tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question i just again would like
a little bit more detail quantifying a
number
you said a number of uh you've had a
number over the past couple years i just
is it like tens hundreds uh
five
uh i would say somewhere between a dozen
thank you for uh representing woodcock
thank you representing the chat but
uh
thank you for taking my question on the
screen uh two
question from before uh can you tell me
approximately or how many uh charter
schools have high school divisions
sure so of the approximately 30 uh
charter schools we have in the state
about 15 of them have high school
programs so it's roughly half okay great
that i didn't have a clue on that one
thank you the second one if i may as we
got this particular bill
uh on the i asked representative uh
codell the same question i want to make
sure we get the same answer not that it
wouldn't be the same answer uh on line
four we talk about enrollment is that
enrollment do you have the other nature
of it in front of you
yes does that enrollment mean
enrollment for admission or continuing
enrollment uh for both okay all right
and one final one so these fees that
you're not application fees
uh that's pretty clear i can't have an
additional fee to apply for the school i
understand that but the fees that uh
representative uh ellison was talking
about these non-fees that you mentioned
that the supplies the curriculum the odd
fees those pieces so under this bill
none of those will be applicable
is that correct
so they wouldn't be applicable in terms
of being a condition for enrollment so
we have some situations right now where
we have charter schools that charge a
fee for supplies and materials
as i mentioned sometimes it runs as high
as 800 or a thousand dollars
in cases where students and families
haven't been able to pay the fee the
charter schools have provided
opportunities for parents to do
community service to the school
but in particular some of the complaints
that we have received involve
students maybe come from single-parent
homes where the parent isn't able to
come to the school and and donate that
level of time in order to make up for
the fee and the way it's presented to
the students and families is that they
either have to provide the community
service or they have to pay the fee in
order to stay enrolled within the school
and that's what would be prevented by
thank you thank you very much thank you
represent cornell
thank you just one question do you know
how many students come from out of state
and attend our charter schools
i i don't off top my head but that's
something that we could take a look at
and provide to the committee
one of the things that
charter schools are able to do when they
accept students from out of state is
they're able to develop their own
contractual relationships with the
sending districts where the students are
coming from from out of state
and those districts or those families
pay a tuition to the charter schools
oftentimes it's a much larger amount of
money than the state of new hampshire is
providing to the charter school for
students so it's an opportunity for
charter schools to make money off of the
students that they're enrolling in other
states
and if that student needs special
education
who's the lea
the services would have to come from the
sending district which would be out of
state
okay thank you so i have a follow-up to
that um
we've had a lot of discussion on charter
schools and where there's a number of
applicants and the charter school can't
house them all there's a lottery
so
if we have a student coming in from
maine
that wants to go to a charter school or
massachusetts
and they're willing to pay this fee are
they displacing
kids that are coming from a residence in
new hampshire
in this lottery it's possible so the way
the lottery is set up right now there
isn't a preference for in-state versus
out-of-state students so if during the
course of that lottery an out-of-state
student was selected and an in-state
student was not selected that would be a
case where the out-of-state student is
displacing an in-state student this
particular language would provide
preference within the lottery system
itself so that out-of-state students
would then fill slots that have not been
wow okay uh represent woodcock had his
hand up first thank you and i appreciate
the larry
lottery clarification and representative
cordelli's bills that the new hampshire
students should have first priority
they if if
a china school
provide requires
funding for supplies and curriculum
i'm confused because in a public school
we can't charge for curriculum supplies
i understand field trips and the add-on
stuff but the fundamental piece how is
it that a child school
can charge a family for fundamental
supplies when they're a public school
i think this is something that we're
trying to correct with this particular
language
um
there are some instances where that may
be appropriate for example in our
traditional high schools there are
oftentimes when a student wants to take
an ap course where the cost of taking
the ap exam that comes with the course
is covered by the student and the family
but paying for the exam is not
necessarily condition of enrolling in
the ap course you can take the class for
free without having to take the exam at
the end so there are things like that
where we don't want to eliminate that
with this particular language we're just
trying to eliminate instances where fees
charged to students are directly related
to a condition of enrollment in the
school
which as you said these are public
chartered schools they should be free
open and public to all students who want
to enroll
thank you thank you everyone you're
welcome represent tanner
thank you for taking my question so is
does this apply to continued uh
enrollment so let's say an out-of-state
student applies
uh year one
and
is able to get in because there's
there's room but then by maybe year two
or three
now the charter school has a lot more
applicants from in-state does that that
bump out that person that student that's
been in that charter school
paying in
a fee a yearly fee
for those three years
because they're now getting bumped out
by in-state students
at that point they would not be bumped
out they would continue their enrollment
in the school because they would not be
part of the lottery they're already a
further questions
maxine thank you very much thank you
interesting topic
yeah
okay we don't have anything else on that
so we're going to take a break and
stretch because we have one more bill i
believe before lunch and that's the
charter conversion school
so we can take a break here and start
thing that back up around 11 o'clock
not many signed in any way in this bill
it is interesting yeah you know i
i just questioned the wisdom of getting
involved with kids out of state when all
of a sudden
you have a pandemic come up and all
everybody's shouting to get in the
charter school but they can't because we
no i haven't done that
we couldn't get reptile labor had it
oh we've been told we've been told a
huge huge group
you know i i had one of the reps right
here say that my whole
school district wants to come and talk
on that thing
and that was uh hobbs
and so uh with that um
we
we have to go we couldn't go to finance
that's being used that room so
we're chasing i'll probably do that
after we can get through this early bill
it's a late bill so it'll probably be in
it's just been postponed because of
safety and security issues and being
able to house all the people we couldn't
oh we have 102 bills that's right yeah
yeah
we got the conversion bill coming up
next
a local district can spend what 80
percent on on a kid i think i haven't
seen that in law but
oh yeah that's the way it was written
you had to have uh the recommendation
the principal superintendent
and then you had the two-thirds of the
teachers had to approve this union
yeah yeah of course that's going to
raise hell here with the committee but
you know i'm just going to be very brief
i'm going to say this is what it does it
makes you know look at washington dc and
and how the charter schools are the
dominant achievers down there
and uh i think after katrina louisiana
went to all charter schools
louisiana louisiana well they did yeah
you
thank you um
we'll move on to our next bill
which is house bill 1132
relative to the application for a
charter conversion school
and uh i will recognize the prime
thank you very much representative
cordelli and members of the education
committee for the record my name is rick
ladd i come from haverhill new hampshire
and representing that area of grafton
county uh in introducing 1132 it's
relative to the application for charter
conversion schools we have in the
statute right now
a law which enables
charters to become charters by two
different routes one we've been talking
about
earlier is there's a separate funding
stream and if you become a charter
school you apply through the state board
of education etc
the charter conversion school is one
that can be done locally in your local
school district we've had one in the
past here i believe that's no longer in
business
but this what this bill does it removes
certain voting requirements that we
currently have in the
process of a public district deciding to
move into the charter conversion school
format
and it adds the requirement that you
have to have a majority vote of the
school district at a regular meeting to
attain that status as a charter
conversion school
in looking at the bill the way it is
right now there's a number of hurdles or
hoops one has to
cross before you can become a charter
conversion school
the charter conversion school right now
of course you have to have the
vote of the school board
to become a charter school but now you
also have to have several other hurdles
which you must cross
one of which is you have to have two
thirds four of the teachers employed
within the school district and
secondly you must have the written
approval of the superintendent and
principal of the school
right now it's my opinion that by having
the latter two requirements i spoke to
right now are just basically saying we
won't have any more charter conversion
schools
that in order to get a two-thirds vote
that's like climbing a cliff that's
straight up and getting the written
permission of the superintendent and the
principal which i i feel often times
don't even live in the community i i
think that that's outmoded legislation
in itself
especially when we have superintendents
and principals to have a higher instance
of moving from one district to another
throughout the state and probably the
average 10-year superintendent used to
be about five years is probably less
than that right now we have 12 vacancies
in the state as at this current time
so what this does it just rewrites the
legislation inserts into you have to
have a majority vote of a special
meeting of the annual meeting or at a
special meeting
and that you have to have a warrant
article that's passed by your community
this would enable a school district then
to move down the route of having their
public school turned into a charter
public school and we know that there's
places in this country where charters
public schools
have shown better achievement results
i.e washington dc
where minority groups had an opportunity
to really
develop and expand their grow and expand
their achievement which that's
demonstrated by various instruments
which we assess something that nape and
aep which is given demonstrates that the
proficiency levels in that particular
city now with these charter schools is
much higher than it was prior to that
so i will close my testimony because
it's just that succinct that it changes
the format in the way of becoming a
charter conversion school which then the
costs are borne by the school district
they still have the responsibility for
funding the charter public conversion
school
and it's controlled by that
that that board itself and the funding
comes through their allocation at 80
percent so that they have monies to run
the charter school thank you
thank you
representative porter saw your hand
first
got it right up there thank you
representative cordelli and thank you
representative lag so i'm not really
familiar with the rules that are working
around our conversion schools but i
understand that in charter schools um
only 50 percent of the teachers need to
be
certified teachers is that accurate that
that's true of the charter uh
public schools the ones we've been
talking about the charter conversion
school it's also true that okay so
can i answer your question no i had
because i have a follow-up so if if a
school decides a school district under
your bill decides to
go to a
charter conversion which i don't i'm not
against a charter conversion i think
there might be some good things to it
but if that um
were voted in by the district
half the certified teachers in the
district could be let go
and replaced with uncertified teachers
is that accurate
i
i would think that to move in that
direction a school board would be
looking at where they are
and
i i'm not familiar i wasn't in this
state when we had i believe was pace
the the charter school which was a
conversion i don't know how that tran
that transition occurred initially
uh perhaps there might be those that
behind me that may have a better handle
on that i i don't want to be subjective
and not give you an answer on that i i
just don't have the information
thank you
representative ellison thank you mr
chair thank you for taking my my
question rick uh i raised this before in
previous discussions about
this
this issue and i guess i'm just getting
back to it again and so what if since we
don't have any current
conver charter convergence schools what
would happen
to labor agreements that had been agreed
to in the school district and the school
board had signed and had in place
three-year labor agreements with their
teachers if in fact they then decided to
go to a
conversion school would those labor
agreements still be in effect
that's a technical question and perhaps
you might ask the
the department there they're available
for this one as well thank you
representative tanner
uh thank you and thank you for taking my
question could you put in a statement
or two of what the basic intent of this
bill is
well right now that
i believe that charter schools
provide that option that's necessary for
a lot of students and we know that we've
seen charter schools
if you want to call them conversions
whatever down in dc they work
and they're able to provide
students what they need the majority of
students what what is necessary for them
to grow and achieve
so um
i i feel that it's it's an option we
ought to have available i know that
we've had discussions whether people
should be certified or non-certified or
whether for example like i always go
back to career tech but we have remember
how we looked for alternative
certification there where it was based
upon the history of the person working
in a technical field before they you
know and they retired and they were
going to come in and offer that school
some of their background information
rather than having the phd it's just
plain old mary mr brown or mrs brown
that has all that good technology and ex
understanding i believe that exists in
public education too
that we have folks that come in that are
not necessarily certified but are
yes
so my question is
what is the intent
of this bill
by removing
the
any input by the people that are running
or involved in the particular school
because the conversion charter school
is actually where
let's say there's an elementary school
in bradford new hampshire
and all that's part of the kearsarge
district and they decide well that's let
me take an easier one grantham has an
elementary school they aren't part of a
co-op
and they
the town decides that they want a
charter school and that they'd like to
use the charter school that's that's the
grantham elementary school
and so they put it on the warren article
i assume that's when it's taken at the
end regular annual meeting that would be
a warrant article and um
so what you're doing is
what's your intent of taking out
teachers and the input of the educators
and the professionals
at that particular school what's the
intent of that
change is tough in education
we have a system that's entrenched
and some call it bureaucratic i call it
you know it's just an entrenched system
that's always last to seize and
recognize often that change
benefits all
and that we're in business not for the
money i put in my pocket but to help the
students and and provide them that
choice of what's best for them if in
fact the community says we're looking at
this and we see this is a better option
for our students and we'd like to see
what the charter conversion can provide
versus the way we're doing it right now
i think it's up to though that the
majority of voters in that town to make
that decision i do not think it's the
job of an employee
to make that decision i don't think it's
the job of the teacher or the principal
to make that decision this education
system we have in america is for the
students and the public and therefore
this is to me is a logical thing that
would go to the regular board regular
meeting of the town or a special meeting
to make that choice in that decision
and and go on from where the decisions
made
representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative ladd for taking my
question
so when you make the comparison to the
district of columbia you're talking
this bill addresses what's going to
happen in a district where a town has a
single public school
for whatever reason
convert that school into a charter
option i don't object to choice
but if you have one public school in a
town
what are the benefits of
converting that school to a charter in
your charter you could write for example
if we have a public library in that
small town
you wouldn't have to duplicate that
public library in that school
you could provide that resource without
having to have somebody with that
credential you could have a public
librarian that's had his expertise in
the field you could also have then the
services that are provided to these
students to achieve the academic areas
provided by people that maybe aren't
licensed and you know and i know there's
a lot of people here that don't agree
with that but i i feel that it's a
viable option and if the community deems
it that's where we want to go they ought
to have the choice to do so
follow up
so
new hampshire public schools
representative are consistently
high flyers we score at the top of
public education scales
uh who's going to make this
determination and based on what that
somehow or another the needs of the
students are not being met in a
community that has one public school
and um
well i'll leave
we've
had a little discussion on that so far
we had a budget bill coming the other
day
dealing with performance outcomes
and we know the performance outcome in
that district versus that district's not
always the same
we also know that we like to boast in
this state that are our children are
highly educated and rank always in the
top five states in the country as far as
achievement and achievement
um
where's the bar placed though you know
when we look at our achievement scores
in mathematics
if we're in the top five
wow
that that's a real concern to me whereas
i know now the proficiency level
is
very very low that bar is a low bar
and when we have 48 percent we used to
have in mathematics
achieving
where we want them at proficient or
higher and now it's only 38
i would say that if i were looking at uh
my child being in education i would say
wow uh what can we do to improve this
and we've been on this steady flat line
or even a declining line for years it's
not all result of
covid or the pandemic
we don't seem to be making the gains
that i'd like to see and it's concerning
and i'm looking now is maybe the
structure of how we function the
organization how we function
you know there's a lot of
issues out there that i
have always advocated that it's not
going to be necessarily a dollar that
nets achievement and growth
it's going to be the attitude of those
teaching in that in that building or in
that site it's going to be the
administration and supervision
it's going to be the aspiration of the
community it's going to be the
involvement of parents it's going to be
the leadership
and the expectation there are a lot of
issues come into play of achievement
that you can't always
gauge by a dollar bill and i've seen
schools that are very in poor areas the
achievement levels in some of those
small k-8 schools is high
and that what's the common denominator
good teaching
good parent commitment and involvement
and on on the list goes all those
tangibles that you have to measure a
different way
uh representative boehm
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question wouldn't it also be
in large town like derry even hudson
where they have multiple
public schools multiple elementary
schools multiple middle schools that
would be
more of what this could be
charter schools provide options you
could have one in a town like that um
it's it's i oftentimes look at the
charter school in my neck of the woods
and it's the only one but it's one of
the finest charter schools you can north
country charter which there's a high
percentage of those youngsters which are
special services within that facility we
all have a seat or so
to go there from the various committed
districts the superintendents got
together and we we put this thing
together
there there's a need for it there may be
a need for having a charter conversion
school within a school district and you
could put that on the warrant and you
could you know it's we've had those
optional type schools located in in many
states i had there were a number of them
when i was up in alaska and anchorage
which we had schools which were highly
oriented in the sciences there are some
that were old-fashioned with their
discipline and that was part of their
charter
so um i think there's a place for this
in our society i'm not saying it's good
for everybody but i think for us to get
there we're never going to get there if
you have two-thirds vote of those which
are employed in the building
representative woodcock thank you uh
chairman uh cordelia remember the lag
good morning good morning again nice to
see you in a formal way i can ask you
questions i hope this
but
thank you um
it's just clarity eric on
line three it hasn't changed it says an
existing public school may vote
by school board so that's that's step
one
and then it goes into the continuation
using the school district and the the
the warrant those things yeah so it's
actually a two-part process it's a
process yes so so the first part is it
has to be the public school school or
that school
correct so the that's the first question
thank you the second one you referenced
multiple times the success of the
charter school
in washington dc
do you know if the funding level of the
school in washington dc is similar to
the final level of the public school in
washington dc
i don't know what their funding level is
but there again it speaks to what i just
did
said a few moments ago i don't think
it's always the dollar
and these charter conversion schools
would be operating on less dollars than
the current system within that community
my thing was my thinking was perhaps the
the public school was funded at a much
higher rate yeah be helpful to them and
the third thing i just want to follow up
on representative mullen's point
she indicated the lack of the school
folks in the decision particularly in a
single school system
and your response was if i heard it
right that that they could use the
public library and they could use other
things to help the academic resources it
sounds to me
like what what you're really saying is
this is a dollar issue this is a cost
savings issue you're outsourcing you're
outsourcing a lot of the services that
our current uh school professional
people provide
that's a definite benefit yes you know
it's a benefit anytime you can save a
dollar that's huge in terms of property
taxes
thank you just want to make sure that
that was the intent of that thank you
representative moffatt thank you mr
chair uh would you believe and then i'll
follow up if i may uh would you believe
that i once served on a school board in
sau 48 the biggest sau in the state nine
towns and the superintendent uh wanted
to have one of those towns one of the
schools problematical
uh converted to a charter school that
was from the superintendent uh and of
course given the current law it was
daunting and almost impossible would you
believe that that that occurred
i believe anything you say represent
moffitt
yes
so my follow-up to that is uh if as i
read this proposal this proposed
legislation
removes that two-thirds
faculty requirement as well as the
superintendent and principles
requirement and as i mentioned earlier
my superintendent wanted
the charter conversion process so my
question is
if i read this correctly is it correct
that 51 percent of the voters in the
district could could
bring about a conversion despite the
opposition of faculty and administration
the the faculty and administration would
no longer be part of this equation it
would just be the majority vote as
you're saying and the recommendation you
know existing public school may by a
vote of the school board so you have
that as well
and then you have the process of that
vote and you have to have the warrant
article
got it thank you you're welcome
representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative
so
three-part question
if a
a town that has one public school
goes to a charter who is responsible for
the special ed program and how is that
funded
second part
what about the budget does the town
still get to vote on the budget for the
school district or is there no longer a
school district it's a charter school so
what public oversight do we have of that
and three would there still be a school
board or would it go to a board of
directors that's not elected
those are all technical questions and we
do have the folks behind me with those
technical answers but yes you will have
special education services provided
because this is a dollar which still
comes from the state of new hampshire to
the charter public school conversion
school
representative cornell
thank you thank you for taking my
question i can't understand from reading
this how this would work in manchester
the largest sau in new hampshire
you don't have to have all your schools
as charter conversion schools you could
have one maybe uh some of those
elementaries that you have now could be
turned over to a charter conversion
school
follow-up my question is how it would go
about happening because we don't have
annual meetings warrants
or the governing charter
which the people on the charter have to
be elected and have long meetings and
then the citizens vote on the charter
and
i would suggest you move to haverhill
this one this would not be able to
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
have you given any thought
to
what the tenor of a school district
would be in which the superintendent the
principal and the teachers
would be told
that they are going to be
employed in a conversion charter the
following year without any input or
have you given any thought to
a mass exodus of teachers or whether or
not the superintendent and the principal
are now out the door or
i'm just trying to figure out in my head
how this is going to play out in real
life
in real life i'm sure that the community
recognizes that mrs smith being a
superlative teacher would keep that
superlative teacher in the charter
if myth
but mrs smith will have to give up the
new hampshire retirement system
and
the collective bargaining benefits that
come with being employed in a public
school is that no i i can't answer that
right now we're getting now into
retirement and i have not looked into
the retirement or
aspect as far as when you get out after
so many years you get this
i would imagine that as a public school
teacher and if you're still certified
you're still working within a public
institution and you'd qualify for that
thank you
any further questions
see none
thank you thank you very much it's
we all agree
thank you very much my name is jane
bergeron i'm the executive director of
the new hampshire association of special
education administrators and i don't
have written testimony just a few
questions so that i can better inform
our members i'm wondering if we can get
a little bit of clarification in regards
to
how special education would work
it's my understanding that the resident
district is the lea this would now be a
charter school
who would be the lea
for this
really this is
really not the time to be asking if he
wanted to uh
contact
representative ladd and ask him or maybe
the uh
representative from the department uh
might have some input to that
okay so i will just pose questions then
i guess that would be one of them and
and i would also ask the question is
this open enrollment so i would use
manchester as an example if one of the
elementary schools decided that they
were going to become a conversion
charter school could
kids from other elementary schools leave
so
how does that all work when it comes to
special education
um i'm wondering if that's been thought
through
the the special education aspects brings
forward a lot of questions and i'm
wondering if if that's been a part of
the thinking
if there are any details around that
this is just a public hearing we're
receiving your input so thank you very
were there any questions i'm sorry
no
good morning nate greene new hampshire
department of education
sure yeah i can try to hit the ones that
i was trying to take some notes here and
listen
so maybe i'll start with uh i know there
were some questions around uh unions and
collective bargaining um so there is a
section within charter law that governs
governs collective bargaining uh and
unions within charter schools themselves
and i'm just gonna
scroll down so i can give the correct
rsa so rsa 194b
14 applies to collective bargaining
in the cases of chartered public schools
charter school employees can form
collective bargaining units those
collective bargaining units have to be
separate from any other collective
bargaining units that might exist so if
we're talking about charter conversion
schools
the teachers within the charter
conversion school would be able to form
a collective bargaining unit but it
would not be able to be the same
collective bargaining unit as the one
that's in the district and that's
because there is a different board of
trustees over the charter school and for
all intents and purposes the board of
trustees is considered the employer
which is separate from the local school
board
i know that was a question as well
whether local school board would have
authority versus whether there would be
a board of trustees
they do operate in partnership and local
school board members can sit on the
board of trustees over the charter
school but there has to be a level of
distinction and they cannot be the same
makeup so you can't have the local
school board be
the board of trustees but you can have
membership across both of those
for the question representative ellison
thank you mr chair uh let me take that
one step further then
given the what if
if we have a three-year negotiated
agreement between
the local school board
and teachers union for example and in
the first after the first year of that
agreement
the town the school board decides to go
to
a charter conversion does that negate
the last two years of the existing labor
contract that that's in fact in effect
i would love to defer that question to
someone that has a legal background or
an attorney because we're getting into
contract law and education law there and
i'm not sure i'm the best person to
answer what would occur in that what if
scenario
thank you representative luno
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much dr green for uh being with us
again today um representative ladd in
his introduction spoke about the um the
potential
savings to the school district if the
school district was to go in the
direction of a conversion
charter school and i was wondering if
you could speak a little bit to
how
how conversion charters are funded
compared to
state board
authorized charters sure so the funding
mechanism is a little bit different
because the funding mechanism still
comes from the
local dollars and so if you have a
charter school that's a charter
conversion school essentially it's run
by the local district it's funded at no
less than eighty percent of the per
pupil cost of the students that are in
that district um so if you were to fund
the charter school at that 80 percent
you would be looking at a 20 cost in
terms of the per pupil expenditures
you can as a district open up your
charter school then to other surrounding
towns and you could develop tuition
agreements with other towns where they
would then send their students and you
would be able to have varying
levels of tuition agreements at that
point that would not necessarily
be governed by that 80 percent local
district funding so for my example if a
student came from a town that was not
part of the district the that local
district would not be responsible for
that student the state would pick up the
cost of that particular student just
like any other state charter school so
in a charter conversion school you you
may have two different streams of
funding the state stream of funding that
would come in for non-resident students
and then the local funding for resident
students
so follow up on that yes thanks so so
just clarifying a couple of points there
um uh if you could sort of you know
repeat and maybe rephrase how the how
the state funding works for um
for students non-resident students
attending a
a school district chartered conversion
charter school
and also whether a conversion charter
school
receives
any direct
funding
from the state
as as
a
state board authorized charters do
sure so it's a little bit difficult
because right now it's a hypothetical we
don't have one that's operating within
the state
but if it was a state student so a
non-resident student attending they
would receive the base adequacy payment
that the state pays for any other
chartered school student in the state as
well as any other differentiated aid
that might be part of that student if
they're a free and reduced lunch student
third grade reading special education
those particular amounts are all
dictated by the state for that
particular fiscal year
for the local resident students they
would be funded by that local
set of dollars at no less than 80
percent of the per pupil cost and then i
believe the state would still pay the
differentiated aid amounts that go into
that as well
okay and a final follow-up on that
and you you just mentioned that the
state doesn't have any operated
or operating conversion charters right
now we have had one in the past what
what happened
uh i think with uh some of the dwindling
enrollment that they were seeing uh and
the costs that were associated with uh
upkeep of that particular program they
determined just within the past year
that they were going to close that
school
and because the school was operated by
the school district it was a district
and local decision and so the state did
not have uh much of a role in terms of
that particular school closing as we
would if it was a state charter school
representative porter thank you mr chair
and thank you
i'm taking my question
the school is not would be a charter
school so there would no longer be an
elected school board that was running it
it would be a board of directors that
would be appointed with maybe a few
school board members on it is that what
you're saying yes okay can i follow up
on that so
when it's time for the local voters to
approve a budget
do they get that opportunity how does
that work if they don't have an elected
school board
to to work up the budget and it's not a
public school anymore
how do they how do i as a voter get to
say yes i approve this budget no i don't
approve this budget sure so in terms of
the funding for a charter conversion
school or any chartered public school
that is being uh opened by a local
district so a district run charter
school
there is in addition to the charter that
sets out the programmatic offerings of
the school there is a contract between
the non-profit and the board of trustees
of the charter school and the local
district and the school board
and that contract sets out the funding
mechanism the rate at which the charter
school will be paid by the local
district
the
different services that the charter
school is going to then provide based on
that funding and the contract is put
before the town as part of a warrant
article and the town has to vote on that
yes
so
who writes that charter
who writes that
application uh it could be a variety of
people
if the
teachers are involved and the
superintendent's not involved and the
school board is not involved
who is writing the charter
so within rsa there are three different
groups or three different types of
people that can start a charter school
so it would have to be one of those
groups generally it's done with
collaborative so my assumption is that
if a school board and a local district
is looking at doing a charter school is
going to involve local members probably
of the school board and any anybody else
that would be
interested in setting up and running and
operating that particular school it's
usually a group of people that are
considered the founders of the school
that write those documents the document
itself does have to be approved both by
the local school board as well as by the
state board of education prior to going
before the town for a warrant article on
the
one more so
why would we want to go this route and
not perhaps make our public school a
public magnet school
and open it and keep
keep
a school board and a budget and all that
kind of stuff and options for kids and
attract kids from other places
then
then become a
it makes me very nervous when we have a
non-elected board overseeing money that
comes from my personal taxes that makes
me a little nervous so i guess i would
like to know how i can be less nervous
and why aren't we talking about magnet
schools and not
charter schools
um so i would say i probably can't speak
to whatever the intention would be
because i think you know this is a very
local decision that we're talking about
being made and so i think there could be
a variety of different intentions in
creating a district sponsored charter
school or a charter conversion school
and i i really don't want to
you know put words in other people's
mouths you know because i'm not sure
what each individual town within the
state might be considering when they're
making these kinds of decisions um the
one thing i would say is that the
pathway already exists within state
statute it has been from pretty much day
one when we created charter schools
within the state so any district right
now can create a district sponsored
charter school that would exist in the
same manner and structure that i've
proposed here it's just this particular
bill looks at the pathway where a local
public school would become a charter
school but a district can create a
district sponsored charter school now in
a very similar pathway
representative
thank you
so
um i'll give you a hyper a question
based on a hypothetical but i hope you
can answer it
so there's
s-a-u-x-y
okay and s-a-u-x-y has one school
okay uh let's say it goes k through
eight
and
the
people in the town are agitated and so
they decide that they're going to
[Music]
convert that to a charter school all
right
doesn't that dissolve
s-a-u-x-y
doesn't that
dissolve
school district uh you know x-y
and so therefore i think
the question is if there's no school
district
no sau left because now it's charter and
it's gone over to a board of trustees
who's responsible for special ed that's
come up like two or three times and
hasn't been answered it's been kind of
goofed around a little bit
um and what's what does the comm
community if at all when they're raising
taxes
uh they're still still going to be
raising swept taxes
and i'm not sure how else it affects
funding maybe representative luna can
get to that but if the if the district
is dissolved and the sau is essentially
dissolved the school board's dissolved
please answer directly about the special
ed but then the ramifications for
uh collecting property taxes related to
schools how can they even
collect property taxes for a local
school if a local school doesn't exist
and what happens to the statewide
education property tax
so there wouldn't be able to be a
situation in which the sau or the local
school board would be able to dissolve
because they're the only ones that have
that ability to do the local taxation
and so
they have to exist because the contract
for running the chartered school is done
with the local school board
in a similar way to the way we operate
pinkerton academy or co brown where they
are public academies essentially they're
non-profit organizations but they
contract with a variety of local school
boards and saus to provide the public
school services for the students that
attend there this would be a very
similar
type of relationship or situation where
the chartered school would provide the
education and the services but they're
doing so under a contract through the
local school board and so the local
school board would have to continue to
exist they would have to continue to
provide the taxation base in order to
operate that charter school it's just
that instead of doing that through a
public school in the current traditional
structure they'll be doing that through
a contract with the chartered school
which would have as well its own board
of trustees
in terms of the special education that's
another reason why the local school
board and the sau would have to continue
to exist because they would still have a
responsibility for providing those
special education services to the
charter school most likely through the
contract language that they would have
in setting up that charter conversion
school
could i follow up on that
yes
so
you don't have a school you've got a uh
sau
the sau
that has to has to exist which i don't
know if that's in statute or not i'd i'd
be very
um
interested to see if that in statute so
in order to have an sau you have to have
a superintendent
okay um
and that's and probably this you have to
have a business manager and you have to
have a few other things but they aren't
able to set a budget
because
the board of trustees are running the
ghost school in that particular
sau
it just uh
i
i don't know if it's been
thoroughly thought through on this whole
thing but in these small districts in
the north
and west and probably even
some you know the
there was a real push to combine schools
and then all of a sudden school started
breaking apart
um
and there are saus where there's only
one school
and
it just seems
i don't know
how to how
how your question where in statute is
that that you've got to have an sau if
you don't have a school
i would have to take a look at that yeah
at the very least you'd have to have the
school board because that's the
contracting entity so the school board
has to continue to exist and because the
charter schools are public entities
their budget
is publicly available and the budget
would be part of the contract with the
local school board so the local school
board would provide the funding the
budget piece would be would come from
the charter school
one more follow-up please okay
how did the conversion school
go back to being a regular school or did
it or did it just fall did did all of a
sudden it just crumbled the whole
so the the charter school that had
closed was pace charter school in
pembroke it was a district-sponsored
charter school i don't believe it
started out as a charter conversion
school it was a district-sponsored
charter school
and so when they closed the students
that were attending that just went back
to the schools that were within the
district already
and then
i guess and there was no
there was no input from the teachers or
the superintendent or
the community that um had to vote that
this conversion school was all of a
sudden
defunct
no it was operated by a board of
trustees and so they had to take a vote
representative mullen
thank you representative uh for taking
for allowing me to ask a question thank
you doctor for taking my question so i
want to go back to eliminating the
superintendent the principal and the
teachers from the decision-making
process here to
the um
opening statements that you made about
collective bargaining
so
it's now my understanding that the
teachers the employees in the
charter conversion could in fact
unionize
but they could not be part of
uh for lack of
uh
just so we're speaking common language
they could not be part of
nea new hampshire
or aft new hampshire
if
somebody on the staff had been
part of that unit prior to this
so they could still theoretically be
part of na new hampshire or aft they
just would not be able to be part of the
same collective bargaining unit that
they had been when it was the
traditional public school so that
particular collective bargaining unit
that was governed by that specific
contract
got it okay but they could be conversion
school number one
yes collective bargaining unit um i had
a second question that i asked
representative vlad oh could i have a
follow-up representative thank you
uh i had a second question that i asked
representative vlad i don't know if you
know the answer to this but um
it has been my understanding and i would
love for you to correct me if i'm wrong
that
teachers that are employed in the
charter school system
are not part of the new hampshire
retirement system am i correct in that
so the statute actually does allow
charter school teachers to be part of
the state retirement system
if you're a teacher in a charter school
you can elect to be part of that system
and the years that you've taught in a
new hampshire public chartered school
can count as service towards the teacher
retirement system
follow-up to that
yes thank you
uh so
who pays the portion of the school i i
mean as it stands right now a faculty
member will pay in their contribution
and then the school pays in theirs
who um
who who does that in the charter
conversion equation so my guess was that
would be probably have to be part of the
contract that they would set up um and
it could be part of collective
bargaining agreements that they go
through as part of setting up that
charter conversion school
okay thank you very much you're welcome
any further questions representative
moffatt
rogue thank you mr chair and by the way
earlier when i said sau 48 was the large
one of the largest districts i meant
geographically as not in terms of
population just to be clear
so right now according to statute if a
conversion is sought
it could be blocked by two-thirds of the
faculty vote and my question
uh is that given that many districts
feature faculty members who live out of
district that start i can think of and i
know of many districts where most of the
teachers don't live in the district
so according to current statute
am i correct to understand that
faculty members who don't even live in
the district could thwart the will of
the local people who may want a
conversion or is that two-thirds vote is
what they get to vote whether they live
in district or not is that is that
accurate
so the way the current statute is set up
uh it just refers to two-thirds of the
faculty so it's regardless of residency
whether they live in the district or not
one question for representative woodcock
thank you roberto i appreciate that i
just wanted
i thought i heard you say during the
early part of your testimony
that you referred to this as your bill
did you write the the
scripts for this bill uh no no i'm sorry
if i said my bill i apologize thank you
you're welcome
representative porter that was a one one
finger up so that's one question one
figure finger up but now i've forgotten
my question oh no you did that to me
um
oh
i'm sorry
i'll catch you afterwards in the hall
i'm here all day two in the morning i'll
call when i
remember uh any further questions
uh
okay you're saving the 2am call dr green
he's going to be glad that i've got it
now okay so um
does this vote of majority
can this vote be hap can a special
meeting be called
by voters in the district to address
this
for example can you get 25 people to
sign on to a petition that says they
want a special meeting to talk about uh
charter conversion and then have that
special meeting
and vote on this and need only 50
percent of 51 of the people there to
approve
it i don't know i admit i'm not an
expert in in town meetings and what's
required to get something out there and
to hold a special election
or a special meeting excuse me
thanks
okay
i do not i see representative porter's
representative ford
thank you mr chair
my question
is a somewhat more general question a
lot of the ones that have preceded
earlier been talking about specific
aspects of how would this affect this
group isn't most of this considered
just a general process you would go
through when you have change of any sort
and then wages and conditions of
employment would be handled through
negotiation and that sort of thing and
so it would shift with whatever the
employer is now this group instead of
that group but the entity still stands
as a school or whatever
yeah i would i would agree with that
this just creates a different uh
structure and framework for that to
happen within well my
my experience being with universities
but when suddenly universities decide to
do away with deans and the dean is the
first person you grieve against
then how do you continue with your
contract and then you negotiate how
you're going to do that sort of thing
that just seems to me to be a process
thing that all this would work out
i was there
i don't know if you want to answer that
as a question or is
yeah so my understanding of the bill is
so
there's a there's a process that exists
now for chartered conversion schools and
this particular bill changes the process
by which that chartered public school
comes into being
thank you very much uh doctor uh i see
one more question uh representative
nelson
chairman thank you for taking my
question
can somebody say someone makes the
switch a town
can the following year they switch back
yes
okay
see no further questions thank you dr
green
and
i will close the hearing on uh hb 1132
and we will be open for lunch until one
o'clock
right
foreign
you
okay we got to get going on these this
afternoon's agenda
but again i'm going to do this every
time we sit down
for those reps that owe me blurbs and
committee reports
please attend to them because this is
going to snowball on us you know we're
going to end up having more and more and
more and so please get those together we
did a great job getting through all that
stuff yesterday
let's just complete that job by getting
the reports in
okay
so as i said i don't have to administer
okay welcome back everybody for our
second half of today's hearings
we have one scheduled started five
minutes ago hb 12-12
relative to charges for charter public
school transportation
and the sponsor is right here with us so
we're ready to go thank you for
attending and you had the floor thank
you mr chairman mr vice chairman and my
colleagues on the house education
committee for the record my name is
maureen mooney a state representative
from the town of merrimack in
hillsborough county district number 21
i'm the prime sponsor of house bill 1212
an act relative to charges for chartered
public school transportation i'm also in
support of the bill as it is
before i launch into this
testimony which in fact i've provided a
written copy for each of you that i know
is distributed by the clerk thank you
for that
i just want to give a small background
on charter school
busing
the way it works and this is for my next
bill as well so it'll be helpful
is located
can ride the district's buses to and
from school
as an example
if you are a resident of manchester
and you attend a manchester charter
school
you can ride manchester buses to and
from your charter school
if you live in windham
merrimack bedford amherst
and you attend a manchester charter
school you cannot
take manchester buses
to and from that school
that's the background
now for the bill
chartered public schools can make
their own school schedules and calendars
independently
from the school districts where they are
located
thus there are days
when the chartered public school may
have a full or a half day
when the school district where the
charter school resides does not
as an example
a chartered school
located in manchester
may have school
on a day the manchester school district
does not
because it's election day
and the manchester public schools are
being used
for polling locations but the charter
school is not
so the charter school independently
making their schedule making their
calendar submitting it on time
designates election day as a day when
they have school
when the manchester school district
on such occasions
the chartered public school
as as in the example i just gave
should not
be charged
for bus transportation on that day
if the public school district calendar
is not an exact match to the public
chartered schools calendar
then this cannot result in an excess fee
to the chartered public
as i mentioned earlier in my bill this
morning and i mention it again
this bill is part of a series that comes
from the ground up
this has been experienced at public
charter schools this is a real situation
in real time it happens
and was requested of me that no charter
schools best as i mentioned in this room
collectively at lunch actually we were
talking i think we now have over 100
years worth collectively of charter
school experience
here with us
so with that intro i want to conclude my
opening remarks i know there are those
that want to testify after me and thank
you so much once again for your
attention thank you very much are there
any questions
yes
thank you thank you very much mr chair
thank you very much representative
mooney for uh bringing this in this
afternoon is this going to affect the
calculation of base adequacy under 198
40a
you know representative i thank you for
that question and at the precise moment
you got to the crunch of the question
that door slammed and i'm sorry i didn't
quite catch the most pivotal point of
your question if you could repeat sure
thank you so uh so as you're probably
aware
our um current school funding formula
includes a uh
the most significant component of which
uh is called base adequacy yes and um
and uh uh that base advocacy cost was
calculated
i believe in
2014 and occluded and it includes a
transportation component so i'm
wondering if this will since this is a
requirement on public schools to provide
transportation beyond what what those
schools would be providing for their own
needs would would it then affect the
calculation of the base adequacy cost
thank you for the question uh i know
there will be those that testify after
me i would say no because it wasn't
enlisted on the fiscal note
and to me your question makes so much
sense and would be so uh evident there
but i don't see that here so i'm going
to have to
answer the question
based on the bill i see and uh and its
thank you very much i i had a similar
type question so i'm just follow it up
when we initially set up uh base cost in
adequacy back in the
uh
we we had an amount of 3456 dollars as
base cost of that three thousand four
fifty six dollars i believe three
hundred fifty dollars of it was made up
of from for transportation for those
students within that district
now now we're talking about students
which are above and beyond that district
that are charter school students
right
yeah that's what i'm talking about too
that the school district doesn't receive
base adequacy for those students that
are not attending
that's that's where i'm going
and so
uh they're not part of our adm a
so
not receiving that funding
is it then not a a financial cost i'm
looking at the fiscal note which says is
indeterminable
but there is that caption at the end
therefore the additional transportation
costs if any the public school district
will financially be
financially responsible for under this
proposed bill is indeterminable so that
it means that
the district's going to be responsible
for the cost of this
additional day or two or three that
you're talking about
is that
how you see it
yes because that's why the district asks
the charter school chart tries to charge
the charter school
for those extra days
yes
my opinion others after me may so just
my follow-up so the charter school is
going to be receiving funding from the
state
to incorporate that cost built into that
base adequacy that they receive
so they are receiving the money but it's
being
it's needed on the other side of the
coin for those extra days
well that's where i appreciate that and
that's where this bill i think would
clarify things on that very subject
well thank you
represent tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
is your intent with this bill
to uh state that uh the
local school district would have to
provide transportation for any time that
the charter schools met outside the
school district calendar yes
thank you
further question representative woodcock
thank you everyone
uh
thank you for taking this question uh
sometimes i have a difficulty
understanding things
uh taking things out of context but i'm
looking at lines basically halfway
through seven and through ten have been
bolded
now if i read
the topic china public school
transportation
and read those four lines as a separate
entity
that might say to me
we're providing transportation
for all china public schools
students
it does not specify the district i know
what you're it may appear to refer to
up above where you're talking about that
specific day when not there but as i
read that as a separate entity it says
to me all pa all
all students
the child full of school feud on a full
day it doesn't say anything about those
above those in local town so if you
extract that
some may believe that this is giving
charter public schools full
transportation from the public school
system
could that be interpreted that way
thank you for the question i'm going to
say no
and the reason why is because in i put
this bill in to have that section be
tacked on
to the existing language that clarifies
what you're talking about
if it were to be interpreted as you
have suggested
i would have put this bill in and
stricken every single thing in that
section except the bold language but i
didn't i tacked it on to that so
charter schools uh only can bus within
you know use the buses
the resident scenario that i described
earlier
within the resident district that
they're located in so i would have to
say uh bottom line no to your question
thank you thank you
representative porter
thank you representative thank you for
answering my question i'm over here
sorry so um let's say it's a large city
and there are six charter schools within
the city and they're all open on the day
that the public schools have closed for
the election
there are 15 students that go to those
six charter schools
the district will be responsible for
driving all over the city and picking up
those
six
students and sending them to the
different charter schools all over or
they may need two buses or
that would be on the school district who
is not having a class that day is that
what you're saying
yes
in the
statute
that i was discussing earlier
chart public chartered school students
are in
are allowed
by law to use the bus system
where they are located for the students
that reside in that district
so
following that
yes go ahead so is it usual within a
district that has many charter schools
to just have one bus that picks up the
charter school kids and delivers them to
the charter schools or do those students
go on the regular school buses and get
dropped off at the charter school as
they go by them
thank you for the question all sorts of
combinations to make uh busing possible
with the roots and the like
i am unaware of any circumstance where a
public school bus won you know is
designated to pick up all of the
charter school students in particular
not to say it couldn't happen
but i'm going to say
i i've got a a question uh an
observation first
uh we have another situation where we
have career technical education centers
operate on different days than the
regular school is maybe in session
it's the responsibility of the
student attending that cte
to transport themselves to
the school the resident school
and then transportation costs from the
resident school to the cte center can be
made up
as an
as a component of the tuition and
transportation formula we have for
reimbursement so i question we have a
situation which is very similar here
that
the transportation from home to school
is not provided on days the school is
not in session
should this not be the same then for the
charter schools that are on a
different schedule than the regular
school or the resident school
thank you for the question it sounds as
though that scenario would be
contradictory to what i'm proposing so
i'm going to have to say i'll stick with
the
language i'm proposing okay thank you
represent woodcock yes thank you
everyone
um
in the towns and one of the towns i
represent they have two child schools
both of them uh totally different one is
primarily an outdoor focused charter
school and they're terrific
they very rarely have ever heard the
term called no school days for snow
because they do bunk with their work
outside
so are you suggesting that the days that
one child school in my town is closed
the public schools are closed but the
outdoor charter school is open because
it's a snow day and they focus on other
activities we should have the public
school buses on a no school day when
it's unsafe to drive
thank you for the question i had to very
carefully follow that scenario
if you need no i've got it i think i got
it
inclement weather uh would be closed for
everyone
they don't know what that word means in
climate weather they do the bulk of
their teaching outside
so you're asking if they would still
have to be bussed based on this law that
that sounds like a local
this law would not be applicable sounds
like a local uh issue with regards to
canceling or not so
i would leave it
to the local district all right
our further questions
nazi thank you very much thank you
um
bob best
good afternoon mr chair
and members of the committee thank you
again for the opportunity to be here
i'll spare you the reintroduction of who
i am since i spoke at the hearing
earlier this morning but i've got a lot
of involvement in charter schools and i
think this bill is a really important
one to consider
i think that there's always discussion
about costs and some details of
coordinating schedules and things like
that
but i think that the the overriding
concern here is
making sure that children have access to
school
that they have access to school for the
whole school calendar all the 180 days
or whatever the art whatever are the
number that are scheduled here
and
the existing statute which is reflected
in the bill that's before you as um
plain text
i think it was intended to do that and
go a long way in that direction which
talks about as
representative mooney had offered that
you're
if you live in the same district as
where the school charter school sits
you're entitled to ride the buses and
then it also talks about using the same
routes and terms and conditions and the
same routes and schedules that already
exist
and i think that the inescapable
conclusion of that
is that the intended law
is that charter school students are
public school students like any other
they're entitled to equal treatment
they're uh titled uh to parity and
and that means that they're entitled to
have a school bus ride to school
if they're lawfully or legally entitled
to do so
um the consequence of this isn't so much
about the cost of a bus or two and um
it's typically the number i think one of
the bigger charter schools in manchester
i think has four buses that provide
students over to it
but it's uh the cost of a bus while
important um isn't as essential as
making sure that the child gets to
school because as we've seen throughout
covid when we've had all of these
discussions about schools being open and
schools being closed when the student
doesn't have access to school
they stay home and their parents have to
do something
charter schools are often younger kids
some of them are kindergarten and on up
the one that i'm involved with in
manchester
begins with sixth grade next year it'll
start with fifth grade and those
students some of the younger ones are
just not able to stay home alone so now
the parents have to make some
arrangement um which they weren't
necessarily planning on um because
there's a surprise in the school
schedule
beyond that
um maybe
i don't know pick a percentage of
students that ride the bus
um the other students who
are brought by their parents and are in
school
are going to continue with their lessons
and that student that isn't doesn't have
a ride to school maybe their parents can
get them to school maybe they have to
stay home and miss school more often
they miss school
um
they
are obviously disadvantaged
by by having that day out of school and
those those have to be the top concerns
for us those have to be the priorities
for us taking care of the kids
yes there is a potential for a little
bit of cost it isn't that the charter
schools are getting the transportation
money and it's not going over to the
school district for transportation money
because charter schools don't get
transportation money that's not part of
their formula since they don't provide
any transportation
it's also the case that
other private schools
in a district separate from charter
schools have this same provision where
their students are allowed to ride buses
and so we've we as a state we've already
sort of decided
let's get the kids to school let's not
sort of parse are you in the right kind
of school are you in the public school
are you in a public
school but it's a different school
because it's a chartered school or it's
something else
um the overriding priority
always has to be let's get the kids to
school for all the days of school so
that they can participate fully
what would happen if the day that where
the schedule's misaligned is exam day
or is a critical day of education in the
in this curriculum that that the
school's after
um obviously could end up being a big
problem
election day is one small example
professional development days are
usually the ones that create the most
uh
disparity because the school district
can put those anywhere on the calendar
that they want and there's usually four
or five professional development days
and
frankly the charter schools are not
picking a schedule intentionally to be
sideways more often than not the charter
schools get a peek at the school
district's schedule and they do their
best to try to match them up but
sometimes it just there's there's
something that misaligns
a half a day of schedule instead of a
full day or something like that
the added cost in the big scheme of
things
certainly
it isn't a significant portion of a
school district's budget
you know if you think that they provide
transportation to all of their schools
for roughly 180 days a year
the idea that they'd have to do a couple
of buses
a couple of extra days for one day of
year isn't even one percent of their
transportation budget much much less
you know percentage of their entire
budget
but it's critical to the students it
really makes a difference for them
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question aren't these the
residents in the town where the charter
school is aren't they also paying
property school property taxes to that
town
yes very much so awesome
oh i'm sorry
follow-up
you're from the town of merrimack would
you believe that merrimack provides
transportation to the cte center even
when they don't have school
i don't know the details of merrimack
but i wouldn't be surprised but isn't
that our goal let's get the kids to
school now cte center schools and i
heard the discussion earlier i don't i
honestly know exactly how those work
because i'm not involved with them but
um
to the extent that there's some
provision for the student to be brought
to the school and then from there they
can get transportation
a lot of the charter school students are
much younger you know they're
kindergartners they're first graders
it's very complicated to it's very
frightening to put a four-year-old or a
five-year-old or a six-year-old
on a bus and hope that it all works out
or they get transportation to one place
and
are
not taken directly to their own school
so that's why it makes a lot of
difference for them thank you very much
uh further questions representative luno
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much again for being with us um
today um you've obviously got a lot of
experience with not only the charter
schools that you've been with as a as a
parent of a
student but also as you mentioned this
morning
your uh representation and work with uh
with charter schools all of my kiddos
went to the merrimack public schools
they didn't i don't my kiddos didn't go
to church okay i'm sorry i
misunderstood that
i have four but they all went up and um
well that's that's not not really where
my question is going mike um the the
you you had you had mentioned in your
testimony just a few moments ago that
one of the charters and i think you said
manchester has four buses maybe or
something like that that's my
understanding um why
why i guess why do they have four buses
um and why aren't they using uh
the
manchester transportation system for um
that's a great question um and my answer
wasn't as clear as it should have been
manchester school district provides them
with four buses
that
that clarifies that and um
and
or it takes four buses to service them
or whatever you would figure that out
and
and thanks and are they being charged by
the um by the manchester school district
for transportation services um
for the school days when manchester is
in in service no the charter schools not
when they're not in service
there's been
discussions about the cost of it and
charging for it i don't know if the bill
has actually ever been sent and paid but
there's always sort of this discussion
about uh we're going to send you a bill
for i don't even know what the number is
but it's
um and
um so
yes there's been a discussion about it
um and then on the other other hand
there's just um questions where uh it's
just not available we're not coming you
can't have a bus on friday because our
our schools are closed and yours aren't
okay thanks
thank you very much are there further
questions
not seeing any thank you very much hey
thank you very much you're welcome
you're welcome baron
good to see you
good afternoon members of the committee
chairman ladd thank you for taking my
testimony bear christina from the school
boards association
we are opposed to house bill 1212. uh
some of the reasons have been um brought
up primarily by representative luna and
representative ladd relative to the
the uh the cost that would be incurred
by local school districts and the um the
transportation
aspect that is embedded in
in the adequacy aid formula
i would caution this committee or at
least remind this committee that the
lack of sufficient transportation
funds from the state to local school
districts is a key component of the
conval lawsuit
if you were to pass this bill you would
simply be adding more costs that are
already insufficiently funded by the
state for transportation so you're
essentially adding fuel to the fire and
um you would be um
you'd be making conval's case that that
state funding um as embedded in the
adequacy aid formula is not sufficient
for all the other obligations relative
to transportation that the legislature
is imposed on local school districts
the second aspect that nhsba has for
opposing this bill is by adding
new requirements for a school district
to provide transportation on students
forced for charter school students on
days that the public school the
traditional public school is not
operational
may interfere with contracts that we
already have whether or not that is a
contract with a private transportation
provider or perhaps and i believe in
some cities
i'm guessing i don't know per se but
some of our transportation providers may
be operating under collective bargaining
agreements with their pertinent cities
so these may have days and vacations and
things of that nature embedded into
whatever contract we're operating under
on whether it's a contract with a
private vendor or a contract such as a
collective bargaining agreement
and last everybody on this committee
knows that statewide there's a
significant bus driver shortage
we have had to get we meaning public
schools have had to get significantly
creative the last number of years and
providing bonuses and providing training
and providing um
uh
other bonus incentives to get more
people to become bus drivers we don't
have enough bus drivers for the routes
that we're currently running if we're
currently being obligated to run routes
on days when the public school is not
open for either an election day or for
inclement weather or if a charter school
was doing some sort of curricular
component on a saturday um i don't know
where we're going to find those people
we don't have enough people to meet our
current obligations by adding more
obligations um it's going to be uh
you're you're just adding to the stress
level um both from a workforce
standpoint um and as well as the fiscal
aspects that the local public school
would be incurring that we would not be
being reimbursed for so for those uh
three general reasons uh nhsba opposes
house bill
1212.
questions representative tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
at least at my school
one of the
more headache type jobs was that of kind
of a
oversight person for the school buses uh
school bus director who uh ran kind of
the dispatch kind of the
karen you know for the school bus
transportation coordinator yeah yeah and
took all the headache calls back and
forth
do all schools have that um and if they
do
that person wouldn't work on certain
days and so that cost has to be added in
as well
thank you for the question
representative uh do all school
districts have a transportation
coordinator i don't know that's a good
question
i'm going to presume not i would presume
in some of our smaller k through 3 k
through 4 districts that's probably left
to the responsibility of the principal
or the superintendent that's a
presumption on my end so the simple
further questions representative
woodcock
thank you representative
mrs christina thank you for taking my
question
uh do you ever have the copy of the bill
in front of you i do yes i'd like to ask
you the same question i asked
representative moody and see if we have
the same answer one representative's
answer i want a legal answer
i'm reading 7 through 12 and i'm
wondering
if a public school is closed for a snow
day
and the charter school is not closed for
a snow day
are our
public school buses that are off the
road because of safety now required to
go on the road and provide
transportation
thank you for the question
representative as i'm reading i believe
it's line 9 through 11. if the district
doesn't have a full day or half day of
school scheduled on the day of the
charter school oh i'm sorry
transportation shall be provided to
charter public schools on all the full
days and half days the charter school
requires attendance i'm reading the bill
and it says if the district doesn't have
a full day or half day of school then
the charter school cannot be charged
implies that we're still obligated to
provide those transportation services
when the public school is not open for
whatever reason the public school is not
open
my interpretation of the bill is that if
the public school is closed for whatever
reason elections inclement weather
whatever it might be but the charter
school is open that the public school is
still required to provide transportation
services that's how nhsba is
interpreting the bill thank you thank
you everyone
thank you further questions represent
yeah just looking at that um i notice it
says
full day or half a day of school
scheduled and if it was a snow day it
would have still been scheduled right it
would have just been cancelled
thank you thank you for the question
representative that's that's certainly
an interesting interpretation that one
thank you
i'd suggest you speak with the sponsor
of the buildo to ascertain intent though
relative to a distinction between
scheduled or cancelled
thank you for taking my question i'm a
novice here so if i ask a question that
everyone knows the answer to please
forgive me
but when we were discussing efa kinds of
things i learned
that
school districts
report for people who are report for
attendance on students who are following
other routes
i'm wondering if in this case
they also report for attendance hence
they are able to receive federal funding
et cetera et cetera et cetera it's not
out of that part of thing but it is
they're still funded for those students
even though they're over here
thank you for the question
representative i i may need some
clarification
so
the public school is tracking
students who ride the bus or are
eligible to ride the bus i i apologize
representative
if we have a principle that
if you draw if you report this student
for attendance which they do and then
receive funding for that
then why if they need some additional
assistance in getting to school would
that be an issue
well thank you for the question i think
i understand well the issue would be
that you would be running
buses and paying for gasoline and paying
for bus drivers that you one had not
necessarily budgeted for
two may run afoul of contracts as i
mentioned
and three i to my understanding those
charter school children that are riding
the buses provided by the public schools
are not the the public school district
is not receiving any funding for those
students
my understanding was they are receiving
funding not for that purpose but they're
receiving funding
the local public school districts
traditional public school district my
understanding if i'm mistaken
representative ladder representative
luna perhaps you can you can correct me
my understanding is that if a true i'm
going to call it a traditional public
school because i fully understand and
recognize that charter schools are
public schools for the just for that
distinction my understanding is that if
a chartered if a public school district
is providing transportation to students
who are attending chartered public
schools the local public school district
is not receiving funding for that
for that for for the purpose of
providing transportation to charter
children i understand that but they are
receiving funds because of that
registration that they report
the state yes the the
if i if
sorry by all means representative um
the only place we have direct
transportation reimbursement by way of
formula is career technical education
we reimburse at 25 cents a mile per
student
and we budget approximately 680 000
for that purpose the actual cost of
districts is closer to 2.7 million
dollars so we're not fully funding that
when it comes to the area we're talking
about here in the regular public school
the funding for transportation is built
into base adequate the base cost
there's no transportation formula where
you get x number dollars school district
it's built in that 3 456 dollars now 3
700 something
and it's there
now
if the other school also receives costs
like that or
funding revenue and it's built into
their base that they're receiving also
that transportation
cost per student which is approximately
well 350 times cost of living now it's a
little bit more
so it could be as high as you know 400
450 dollars
on a per people basis for the year
so that's the only source of
transportation revenue the districts
receive on this
it's not a money-making affair and
that's the issue we have buses running
now with one-third capacity
on a 66 passenger bus for elementary
kids
it's not paying labor it's not paying
insurance it's not paying you know
replacement car any of that stuff
so i think that's how we're working
thank you thank you mr chair and
representative ford i'm going to read
from the convail lawsuit
the current state funding
current state funding incorporates a
base universal transportation cost of
three hundred and fifteen dollars three
one five three hundred and fifteen
dollars per pupil so the state is part
of your adequacy the thirty seven thirty
eight hundred hours after
that public schools get per child 315 of
that is to provide for transportation
services
next paragraph from the convail lawsuit
there is not a single district in the
state with 10 or more pupils whose
transportation costs are less than 400
hours per pupil so the argument is that
districts are being
expending
more than 400 hours per student to
provide transportation services just for
the traditional public school children
we're only getting reimbursed 300 no
we're not even reimbursed we're only
being getting revenues of 315 dollars
per student and now we're being asked to
add additional students on different
days that we have not budgeted for and
we're not getting any adequacy for
the other aspect to that if i may i
wasn't planning on going down this route
but um
uh your annual meetings are in um
another six or seven weeks um so our
budgets are pretty much set budget
hearings were within the last two weeks
budgets are going to be set in another
in the middle of march um so
if if we're adding costs through this
bill
you know i don't it's
local property taxes are going to go up
next october because we're gonna have to
pay for more stuff without getting any
are there any other questions of uh
bear christina from the school boards
association
everybody good
representative nelson thank you mr
chairman
thank you for taking my question
on a snow day
okay
are they made up automatically
in other words if you take a snow day
you have to make one up at the end
thanks thank you for the question
representative no um the law requires we
had a little conversation i forget if
you were here or not representative um
when chairman kline from the state board
of education spoke about i forget the
bill number when we were talking about
the remote instruction versus in-person
instruction um the law requires that
school districts when they're building
their calendar
build in 60 additional hours for
inclement weather so one snow day no you
don't have to make that up at the end of
the year
once you start getting into seven eight
ten school day snow days you would have
to tack on
days at the end of the school year thank
you
further questions
thank you very much thank you very much
okay uh next and last person i have a
thank you mr chairman for the
opportunity to speak and committee
members
i'll be brief i think we've covered a
i think the purpose of this bill is to
make sure that the kids are getting to
school that's really in a nutshell we're
now talking about a lot of days we're
talking about the rare instance where
schedules may not align for whatever
reason but we're trying to get the kids
to school the kids that we're talking
about for the most part are probably k
through 8 9th and 10th graders perhaps
[Music]
some of the districts may not allow the
kids to ride the public transit even in
high school
i'm not sure where that lands right now
but
i'm hearing a lot of people talk about
it's it's a lot of money it's a lot of
money it's a lot of money and it is
money is important people who know me
will say i'm cheap i mean i'm pretty
tight with my cash and we run our
charter schools pretty tight
but at the end of the day we're talking
a couple dollars per child
per day
and
we're talking about maybe a day one trip
or two trips
the kids that are going to be impacted
are the kids that need to be in school
their parents are working they don't
have transportation maybe to bring the
kids to school we need to rely on the
buses and it's not for a lot of days
other issues and we're hearing contracts
collective bargaining etc those are
important but they'll get worked out
when this is resolved again we're
talking about one or two three trips out
of an entire school year
i certainly would never expect the
district to bus children if there's bad
weather i just wouldn't expect that i
wouldn't want to put bus drivers at risk
i wouldn't want kids on the buses if
it's that bad so i'm not sure that was
ever intended to be that way
the rest of it i think we can work out
um
it's not a lot of money i think it's
more important that we're getting our
kids to school safely making sure the
kids that don't have transportation if
there's not a bus or getting to school
and then they're able to get home
thank you thank you very much other
questions
being familiar with a
charter school and how it runs is there
an attempt on the part of charter
schools to try to align calendars so
they're agreeing with the
the district calendar for example
starting at a certain time either prior
to labor day or after labor day that's
been contentious throughout the state
and then of course you have the other
days within for professional
days in service days
so is there an attempt to try to align
these calendars so they are on the same
scheduling
i can't speak for every charter school
but i can speak for the school leaders
that i've interacted with which is quite
a few and we all try to work with our
districts we call and ask you know this
is when we're looking to start this is
when we're looking to end our day
we're looking to get a copy of their
calendar so we can build our calendar as
closely as possible to it
everybody wants to collaborate with the
districts it's just once in a while
there's an off day whether it's exam
week or something comes up sometimes
it's just something's missed
and but we want to make sure every child
has the opportunity to be in the school
when it's open thank you very much
representative porter i see your hands
up thank you thank you mr chair and
thank you as i'm sitting here thinking
um
there are different models of education
some schools
you have six weeks on three weeks off
that kind of thing a different calendar
form of calendar if one of our charter
schools was to decide that one of the
ways they wanted to innovate was to play
around with the traditional school
calendar and like go through the summer
and have longer breaks at one time and
shorter breaks at other times if they if
they did that and that was part of their
contract or their application
would then if and say they were open two
weeks when the schools were closed
or they were closed three weeks when the
schools were open would they be would
the public schools then be responsible
for transporting those students during i
mean i'm not trying to be difficult here
i'm just trying to think of
something that might happen in the
future very i mean my ideal school was
open all year long and having blocks of
time that were different than the
traditional i thought that might be
beneficial to the learning of kids
especially over the summer etc so if
someone came forward with that
would passing this bill
then require
the public schools to transport the
students when they were not even open at
all
for long periods
um i i
would venture a guess that yes but that
wasn't the intention the intention is to
operate within the normal
school calendar year and try to cover
those days that are missing
so not looking to transport children
are there further questions from the
committee yes represent
thank you and thank you for taking my
question um you said about
you concentrated on working it out with
the with its districts as far as
calendar issues were concerned have you
tried to work it out as far as the
amount of money the
extra days would cost
to for uh transportation or
or any
anything on that line
we've received the cost per bus per trip
from one of the districts that we have a
school in
um
we're trying to work it out with them
that's why we try to align our calendars
as best we can
again most of these days are just
it's an off day whether it's exams or
there's something going on that the
school is participating and on the other
side of it i know some schools have
longer days more days off and the school
districts don't have to transport them
for
maybe it's the week of thanksgiving at
all or they have a longer holiday break
they have different days off where the
school districts do not have to
transport and we work very hard to make
sure that they have access to those
calendars and are aware of that at the
beginning of the year right
just as a follow up on that my question
was not about the calendar because i
you've made it quite clear how
you tried to work it out with them on
calendar what i'm asking is have you
tried to work it out with them
financially
on how much it costs this district to
provide that extra busing and and how
much they're charging you in other words
to come to some agreement that way
financially
i can't speak for every school i can
only speak for the ones that i've been
involved with and we've had discussions
about the cost and i could be wrong but
my recollection this was about three or
four years ago my recollection is that
they have a set fee for their buses per
day
to use it
yes so uh could you give me an idea what
that fee was
i want to say it was roughly
for some reason 238 dollars one way is
what's sticking in my head per bus
so i could be wrong and that's going
back probably four years now i'm sure
it's escalated with gas and everything
else but um
it you know it was significant enough
we were looking one day one of the
schools actually had more buses
and i think we were looking at closer to
two thousand dollars for the day charged
to the charter school and it was
for exam week or something for one of
the days
thank you very much further questions
not seeing hands thank you very much
thank you very much have a good
afternoon you too
i don't believe we have any more cards
on that particular bill so we're closing
this hearing
and preparing to go into the next
represent moody mooney you're welcome
back
okay
so the bill we're opening up right now
is 1453 that's relative to
transportation to a charter public
school
thank you so much
for the record my name is maureen mooney
state representative from the town of
merrimack that's hillsborough county
district number 21. i'm the prime
sponsor as well as a supporter of house
bill 1453 an act relative to
transportation to a chartered public
school
i provided written testimony for all of
you
and that's being distributed now i begin
it with
the background and the scenario that i
did for the previous build just now so i
don't think i have to repeat that
it seems to me as though it's clear as
to how it works in terms of busing so
i'm just going to go right into it
house bill 1453
expands
rsa 194
dash
b
colon 2
roman 5
to ensure the phrase same terms and
conditions applies across the board when
it comes to bus transportation
the bill
for bids
transfer stations
depots or terminals
if
big distinction here if
the school district where the chartered
public school is located
doesn't have
transportation
transfer stations
depots or terminals
for their
public school district students
a transfer station
a depot
a terminal
is another location
where students congregate or are dropped
off to essentially catch connecting
buses to their final destination
i would provide the example of when
you're flying
and you have a flight ultimately to la
but you have a connecting flight you
have to catch
in chicago
the same thing happens
with bussing
a student may be bust
at a location oftentimes another school
dropped off
waits
connecting bus arrives boards that gets
to their final destination
i'm extraordinarily
in awe
and sympathetic
to the busing
transportation companies
they do an extraordinary job
and i've worked with them
in manchester i'm familiar with the bus
coordinators in manchester the public
school bus coordinates manchester i've
never met a more organized professional
group in my
life
they do a great job
and i know that they're doing the best
that they can with roots and the like
however
we are asking
if
depots and terminals are not used
for public school districts
then they not be used for the chartered
school students that are within those
districts as well
that will conclude my testimony thank
you mr chairman thank you very much are
there questions
representation
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question
private schools also have the same
requirement but when our private school
in town
had
students
on the public system going to the school
they were all met at the middle school
and then driven
to the private school
um this would not allow that
so you're saying could i um thank you
for the question i just want to clarify
you're saying in your scenario that both
private school and public school
students in that district were brought
to a location no just a private school
student okay
they were all met at the middle school
and then a bus took to the private
school
public school and private school
students all met at the middle school no
just private well all the students that
went to the middle school all met the
middle school but then the students that
went to the private school also came to
the middle school and then they were bus
to the private school understood my bill
is related only to students of a
chartered public school
but that would be the same instance
where that would not be allowed sounds
very similar yes i you're bringing in
private schools which is a whole
thing yeah the private schools stop the
transportation because the hours
wouldn't die understood but just to
clarify my bill
public chartered school students
following on
to the previous one because we do that
in hudson
and they go to the elementary school and
they are supervised by teachers and
gotten into they have little lines and
they get them into the lines before the
buses show up and it's it's i think it's
more than a bus
because we have a pretty big private
school and they've been doing that
i've lived there 38 years and it it's
been going on all this time
why would it be inappropriate
for a charter school system to use that
same system that's been working for the
local
why would it be inappropriate to work
for a charter school when it's been
working for the local
private school for all these years
without a problem
thank you for the question
um i know that those who are going to
testify are closer to this issue at this
point than i am however when i was
involved in this um and had been exposed
to it
not every school
that's designated as a depot as a
terminal
is as a ready
perhaps well staffed or coordinated as
the one you just described
it could sometimes
be a safety issue it could also be a
delay in transporting the students and
so forth so it sounds like in that
scenario it may work
yes go ahead
would it not then make sense to instead
of forbidding it
putting some guidelines on it that says
they have to be supervised by school
your personnel or something instead of
just saying you can't do it when it's
something that is working for some towns
very good question i appreciate it
i agree with that i would be open to
that but i hesitate
because yet again another layer of rules
and regulations
uh on bearing on the backs of our
administrators and our teachers to now
come up with a new set of rules because
they have students coming in and being
dropped off at depots and there's a
period of time where they have to be
supervised so i'm torn on that
open to it but torn on it knowing the
realities of
when rules and regulations come bearing
down from concord on our administrators
and our teachers
thank you for that question thank you so
i i have a
follow-up to where we are with this
conversation and questioning the issue
of supervision
uh we have a responsibility
all all educators have responsibility
make sure that these
students
all my youngsters are under proper
supervision and you come in from home to
school a where the
the transfer is made
you might have several buses coming in
from different directions so you could
end up with a number of kids there
on the days that no teachers are there
and oftentimes it's of teachers on the
playground
which are supervising other students
going to that resident school right
there who also supervise these students
which are going to go on whether to a
middle school or to a charter school and
that's that's common
uh what will we do on those days when
there's nobody there to do the
supervision
and
that bus drive the bus drivers couldn't
leave unless there's an adult they're
supervising
a house is going to work
with the supervision that's needed
of the students which are being dropped
off at that transfer site and waiting
for the students come in from another
site
and then all those students get on to go
to the charter school thank you for that
question i can only think my bill would
help in that scenario in that it would
uh of now forbid this kind of uh
hypothetical as you describe where we're
having more terminals and depots my bid
okay thank you very much representative
mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
so
uh i'm trying to wrap my head around the
logistics
um
i'm your neighbor in bedford our town is
we've got six kids or seven kids going
to a charter and they're coming from all
different directions
and we can't
intersect anywhere or uh for them to get
off of one bus and get on to another bus
so
do you foresee this as
a a dedicated bus for those children
i'm the kids in our community get on the
bus at home and get off the bus at
school
but they're routed and they're all going
to the same place can you
take me on a ride
from
your house where you're leaving as the
chartered school student and
not having to get off the bus
yes thank you for that
um
so
if i live in manchester
and i'm a student
and i attend a
chartered public school in manchester i
am entitled to ride the manchester
school bus to go to school
there may be a scenario where i am
picked up at my home
in manchester
and driven to
another school
i have to wait
the bus i was just on takes off
i wait for now another bus to arrive
i board it and it would then take me to
my charter public school
the place i just was could be another
school
i believe
for coveted precautions i believe there
was a large depot in manchester that was
not a school but a facility that could
certainly uh be a terminal and so forth
so that would be uh the scenario
um what we're saying in the bill is
again if if manchester isn't doing that
kind of a route
then it shouldn't for their public
schools
then it shouldn't be done for me the
manchester chartered public student
to have to make that
terminal stop before i get to my final
destination
yes
except that the other
students
are getting on the bus
as a group
along a route and all going to the same
place
so they don't have to get off because
that bus is picking them up and taking
them all to the same place
i now live amongst those kids but i'm
going
halfway there and then i need to go in a
different direction
is there i mean i can't see any other
option other than having you know a
dedicated driver pick that one student
up for
the four students that it applies to
however many um
how
how are they going to get from their
home to the charter school without
having to stop somewhere
certainly a bus
could pick up
students from multiple schools
and make stops along the way direct
stops
but they can't have a terminal
connecting flight for lack of a better
word
so i'm not
saying in my bill you know a designated
bus to go to you know this school and
another to go to just to that school
another to go to this school
i'm saying bus companies can come up
with routes to collect everybody that's
going to a different school and making
stops then at all the schools of the
people i've just picked up
without any connecting stops
so when i let you off as the bus driver
it's
my bill would say it's going to be to
your final destination
it's not going to be to a a median
destination
could i just have one quick go ahead
in our community we have uh
rules about how long students can stay
on a bus
so
i believe it's their the goal is to have
the little ones on the bus less than an
hour
have you given any thought to how long
it might take if there were
15 kids scattered all over manchester
that somebody had to be the first kid
picked up and somebody's going to be the
last have you given any thought to that
i have not in consideration of this bill
um and i'll tell you why i'm trying to
as best as possible
but succeeding the goal of what this
bill intends to do
allow as much flexibility as possible
within reason
of those who so diligently put these
thank you
represent tanner
uh thank you and thank you for taking my
question i live up in sullivan county
and
um
the two districts that are really close
together where i live uh or where i go
by as i
travel down here or sunapee and
kearsarge
and there's a stop
um along one of the lakes
where the every morning when i come
early for these committee meetings
there's a kearsarge bus
waiting
for a sunapee bus
so that they can transfer students
because in the in the back country of
new hampshire
the roads
don't they aren't like the streets in
manchester
and the school district uh kearsarge has
eight towns and it's one of the largest
geographical
school districts in new hampshire
and they have the probably the heaviest
transportation budget
and in order to make it efficient and
they've contracted with nearby districts
to have
these roads that kind of naturally lead
to each other to have these areas where
they meet
this bill that you have offered here
would mess up their system tremendously
depending on where the charter schools
were and
i'm just wondering if you thought at all
about how this is going to affect the
rural areas of new hampshire
thank you for the question in the
scenario you provided
was there a chartered school
involved
i'm not sure that there's a
charter school there's there's a couple
of private schools in our area and
those students uh although they you know
there's this bus switch between
districts at a certain location where
certain students go back and forth but
then they're transported to their
individual schools whether it's an
elementary school
elementary slash middle school
and then from there
if there's further transportation then
the then the bus
another bus or that bus depending on how
you know they work it would go to the
private school or the
assuming the charter school which it
seems like you're saying that's not
that's not acceptable
i would thank you for that clarification
and question beforehand
i would argue
that my bill does not apply to the
scenario you described
because of the big if
word
the bill says
if
the school district where the charter
school is located isn't doing it
you can't do it for the chartered school
students either
but in your scenario it sounds to me
like the school districts are doing it
so therefore it would continue to be
allowed
yes
um
so
i don't know as it's that much different
than representative mullen's
uh
idea
what it seems to me that you're saying
and just
this is like
a question
do you are you trying to say that
even in our rural areas
that if there's a charter school
within that rural area at some point
kid a who's a charter school student
gets on bus one
and that same bus one whether it's from
kearsarge sunopee or whatever
has to end up at that charter school
without any
any connection anywhere
because that's what it seems to me like
thank you for that
is to the chartered school
that's
okay even if part of that depot is the
buses sitting
and the kid has to change from a
kearsarge bus to a sunopee bus because
the the roads and the towns inter
intersect
and in that scenario
it sounds and thank you for that in that
scenario it sounds as though because
your school district is
is doing that sort of exchange
they could continue doing so
and that would be
but the charter school student wouldn't
get on bus one and end up at charter
school on bus one and that seems like
um
a transfer of bus
would not i mean necessarily be a depot
or a terminal
um
being dropped off and waiting for a
and i want to just further add yes i
have considered um charter schools
collectively throughout the state
when sponsoring this piece of
legislation
thank you very much
i
if a school some of our school districts
single town school districts are very
geographically large
and so in order to keep kids from being
on a bus
for hours we run a lot of buses right to
pick from all over the place and bring
into the school
but if you have a charter school
and you can't let it let that student
ride the bus from their neighborhood
the same bus that all the other kids are
taking to the school and then have the
school collect up all of them to take to
the charter school what you're going to
have to do is either run a whole bunch
of empty buses
or you're going to have to run one bus
say you've only got 15 kids or even if
you have 20 one bus all over the entire
school district at all those desperate
pla disparate places
and that could take hours to do that to
pick up all those kids
and i'm i'm not sure why you would
prefer that to having them meet at
another school and take a single bus
to the
charter school thank you for the
question i would just go back to that
word if if the school district where the
chartered school is located
does transportation precisely like you
just described
then it's fine for the chartered public
school as well
but the chartered public school student
should not be in a situation where they
are brought to terminals
and depots
and the public school students where the
school is located is not
but that was not my question
my question was the pro the traditional
public school
all the kids go end up at the school
that they're going to they don't
transfer them but a charter school would
either have to transfer them there or
would have to run a bus over the entire
district to pick up all those charter
school kids from one end to the other
to do it straight
and i'm wondering why you would prefer
kids stay on the bus for a couple hours
potentially i know how long it takes
in my just in my town
if i was to run in and out of all those
neighborhoods
why you would prefer that
to having them meet at a public school
where they can be bussed to the charter
school
because
if my town does you know if everybody
else gets bused to their school
just to be thank you for that just to be
clear i don't prefer that students take
forever to get home or that they have
longer routes than necessary the purpose
of my bill is to make it
fair for what's done for public students
is done for chartered schools and
oftentimes terminals bus depots and the
like are not the best scenarios for a
route to or from school the best
scenario would be the connecting the
direct flight for lack of a better word
or the direct route in a scenario like
you're mentioning where it's more
complex yes i would imagine the bus
coordinators would have to do some more
um
uh routing and organizing in that way
but it is certainly not the intention at
all uh to prolong a student's drive to
thank you thank you very much
further questions jefferson woodcock
i'd like to follow if i may represent if
you take the question on representatives
comment
it seemed to me
i know you were differentiating between
his public school and private school and
child schoolies
but let me give you his exact scenario
as it happens with ireland rural area
without using the term private
we have five buses
pickup youngsters come to the middle
school
everybody gets off there
and the five chatter students as well
and from that
site a new bus comes it picks just those
child students up and takes them away
so you're telling me that is not
acceptable
thank you for that scenario um
that is a unique one certainly
um
the fact that uh you know you start out
by saying the scenario is for all public
school students and that they're all
brought to the middle school
those that go to the middle school those
that go to the middle school so when the
connecting bus comes it picks up only
chartered school students correct
because all the other kids are at the
middle school
okay that would be a depot that would
not be well it's a school right right
sometimes deployed transfer station
airplanes makes me seems more cold than
it is that that current system they've
been using for 40 years not not working
for you but in this scenario yeah well
okay that's all i got you're clear i got
it let me just add to your scenario may
i sure if rather than allows it
if
just to be clear on what my bill does
if in your scenario
the public school district students the
chartered school district students are
all brought to the middle school
some stay because they go to the middle
school
well this is my scenario
yes please
go to the middle school
those that go there stay
a bus comes up and picks up chartered
public schools and perhaps some public
school students who got dropped off
there but they don't go there they get
on as well my bill would not apply
but we only have one middle school so
they all get off there
okay we can go hours on this thing and a
lot of different scenarios because there
are a lot of different scenarios
there are and i just let you know one
last one i'm looking at
we're trying to do the same thing with
all our students on an activity bus
after school
running that around through haverhill we
cannot do it and keep those kids on for
less than an hour and a half some of the
kids riding on that bus
so the same thing would occur we'd have
to consolidate you know instead of using
all the transfer sites and the different
buses we have we'd have to use one bus
and that one bus scenario i'll be honest
with you it won't work in my town
because we have just two we have 96
miles of road
and
kids are scattered all over and this is
all rule back in the country type living
uh they'd be on the bus for well over
the time that we're allowed to keep us
up by kids on the bus due to education
rule
and and good safety and best practice
so i think that you know there are a lot
of scenarios which we got to work out
and i'd be glad to work with you and
trying to work some of these
these difficult situations out
without a doubt and i think you'll enjoy
hearing from the speakers coming after
me as well thank you very much
uh
let's see
are these
ones
sorry kim lavalley from mont vernon
thank you it's good to be back
um i am speaking in support of hb 1453
and again i would just like to stress
line 11
public school unless the use of such
transfer stations depots or terminals
also applies to the transportation of
non-chartered public school students
we're looking for
equal transportation i understand that
they're i'm not going to rehash a number
of scenarios that everybody's talking
about
but just trying to keep it equal making
sure that the charter kiddos are not the
ones getting dropped if it can be
avoided and having them get
to their school in a timely manner as
well
thank you thank you very much other
questions
not seeing your hands thank you very
attorney best
thank you mr
chairman and members of the committee
for the opportunity to be here for the
third time today um to talk about the
bill um again my name is bob best i'm
from merrimack and i've got a lot of
involvement with a whole bunch of
charter schools and i won't bore you
with all the ins and outs and details of
that um i think that some of the message
that you've heard for the presentation
of the bill is what i want to focus on
and i want to make sure that i touch on
some of the scenarios that we've heard
discussed here
this bill is really i call it sort of
equal protection
the equal treatment
treat all the students in this district
the same if you use depots for your
students then you can use them for
charter school students that's fine
kearsarge and sitting on the waiting the
bus if that's what you do for the for
the public school students
absolutely fine to do it for charter
school students use terminals as long as
you're doing it equally for everybody
so be it it is what it is but treat
everybody fairly don't do it for charter
school students if you don't do it for
the traditional public school students
and that's what this bill is really all
about
and some of the places that this happens
um pre-covered
there were some situations where
even though the existing law says use
the same buses and routes
they were not using the same buses and
routes they were bringing all the
charter school students to a terminal
and everybody else that wasn't a charter
school student got some other kind of a
treatment and that's just not fair
charter school students are public
school students like any other and they
don't deserve second class treatment on
that
but if the school district uses
terminals and they use them successfully
as you described
terminals are hard you talked about
supervision what do you do when the
supervision isn't there all that has to
be worked out but if you're using
terminals for all the district schools
fine that's okay use it for the charter
schools too
just don't use it for one set of
students and not the others
during covid the use of terminals really
expanded especially in manchester
with good reason it was all the reasons
that you talk about busing is
really challenged right now hard to find
drivers hard to find the costs hard to
find space on the bus where you have
less kids on the bus because you're
trying to keep them all a few feet apart
all of that um and so it got more
complicated
and the way that manchester did that was
they had terminals located around the
city where all the parents had to bring
their own kid to the terminal from home
and then from the terminal they would be
taken to their school
and
lots of reasons to criticize that and
not love it especially with the little
little kiddos the four and
five-year-olds and them sort of
all the best supervision that you're
when that system is sort of
put behind us for
the other schools in town
but the charter school students still
have to have their parents bring them
from home to a terminal to get on a bus
to go to the charter school
you've got a clearly unfair unequal
treatment of schools for no reason other
than
we
have a preferential treatment for public
school students and not for charter
school students and that's really what
this bill is
getting at and
and is the important thing to tackle
charter school students are not second
class citizens they don't deserve when
they go to a terminal they're actually
on the bus longer because they go from
home to you pick the school they get off
the bus and they sit and they wait and
in the wintertime they wait in snow or
they go into the gym or whatever and
somebody's trying to supervise them but
they don't really know the kiddo because
it's not from their school
but they you know can count heads and
they do their best to try to keep track
of all of them um
in one situation with one of the charter
schools that i represent they did have
kids go missing at the middle school
that they were at the other elementary
school that they were brought to
um and you know caused that momentary
panic
but if you're doing all of those kinds
of things as a matter of your usual
course fine so be it
but if you're not if you're going to
give better bus service to the local
kids than you are to the charter school
kids it's not fair that's not right it's
not what the original statute before
this amendment intended and it's
certainly not what should happen with
this amendment
as to all the scenarios about hey this
works for us and we've got a scenario
and all the kids come to those things if
that's the system you're using in the
district for the public schools where
you're using transfers or terminals or
depots or whatever you want to call them
so be it go ahead continue to use those
um i'd love it to be better um but
the kids on the bus longer when they
come from home wait around at a bus
terminal for the right bus to arrive and
then get a second ride to another place
they're waiting at that school for five
minutes or 10 minutes or 20 minutes and
then they've got another ride to the
other school
that makes the the kiddo school day
longer
it makes them
you know experience a different
educational experience than other kids
in their school district and that's not
right
those those
kids have activities and homework and
all that
just like every other kiddo and the time
on the bus matters just as much for them
as it does for others
i anticipate there's a little bit of
discussion about special after school
weekend saturday even in the earlier
building was discussed about saturday
none of these bills deal with anything
to do with extracurricular activities or
club sports or
weekends or any of those kinds of things
the statute only the original statute
only requires transportation to school
for school days
it's never required any of those other
things so even a school district that
provides transportation doesn't have to
provide transportation for the golf team
or the baseball team
if they choose not to do so it's not
legally required and sometimes they make
choices sometimes they allow it for one
sport and not for other sports those
things happen all the time and it's got
nothing to do with what's going on in
this bill
this is simply about
saying
when a parent exercises their choice
which is what charter schools are
educational choice i want to go to a
different school for whatever my reasons
that my kid is still
a citizen of the town we're treated
equally we're all we're all the same
representative porter
thank you mr chair um thank you sir for
taking my question so you are saying
that the scenario that representative
woodcock had presented where all the
kids in the town are brought to the
middle school
the public
middle school kids go into the classroom
the charter school kids get on a bus to
the charter school is not allowed under
this bill
i i there was a bunch of different
scenarios discussed and it's important
to sort of understand the details of
each individual one but um
understand that the use of terminals
today or or that kind of thing is
already exceedingly rare before covid
there was a couple of school districts
that were doing it and most of them were
doing exactly what what could be done in
this situation you have buses that come
from around town they drop the kids off
at one school and then they go to the
other school and drop the kids off at
the other school
it's five more minutes down the road and
the buses are on their way
and that's what you know manchester has
done and virtually every other school
district where there's a charter school
but that's not allowed in this bill
you of course that's a lot in this bill
yeah but their kids were charter kids
were waiting at the middle school for
another bus that's not allowed
not unless unless the school district
i'm sorry
my apology
get too excited
the middle is the whole town
all the middle school age children in
the town are brought to the middle
school
most of them go to the middle school
five of them go to a charter school all
the other kids go into the middle school
the five kids that go to a charter
school get on another bus that takes
them to the charter school
that's not allowed under your bill no um
well
i don't i don't know if i get to claim
it be my bill but um yeah yes that would
not be allowed so what if it was the
same bus what if all the children got
off the bus except for the same
five charter school kids and they went
on the same bus to the charter school
would that be allowed yeah
of course
what's the difference
um you're treating all the students
fairly you're treating them all equally
they all get treated with the same
system we don't employ terminals and
make kids get off the bus and get back
on the bus and know which bus lee or
maybe they miss their bus at that
transfer terminal which has happened
all of those things are possible
treat them like you do every other
student make your you know
really what happens with the solution is
much simpler than that because the bus
companies are really good at making
routes and they figure it out but all
the other students aren't staying on the
bus and going to the charter school
so they can't be treated the same
because they're going to two different
places
i i'm sure that if i was asking you to
drop them off at the charter school
first we wouldn't even
i don't think i'd survive that
conversation but yeah again there's got
to be some level of difference obviously
the kids got to get off of the bus at
different places
okay are there further questions
not see any questions thank you very
much
thank you
and the last individual on this bill is
my apologies again i didn't mean to talk
good afternoon again members of the
committee thank you chairman lad barry
christina school boards association
opposed i'm not going to spend a lot of
time on this bill i think
the concerns on hsba have uh has are
have been sufficiently flushed out um
first i do want to thank representative
mooney for a couple of things her desire
to try and help kids that seem to be
having um some challenges is is obvious
so we we appreciate
her dedication to this issue second i
would also like to thank representative
mooney for um clarifying
what a um a transfer station is and she
means that in the context of bus
transportation
i i'm not lying when i first read the
bill i expected to come in here and hear
some horror story that a public school
was dropping some kids off at the town
dump and they were having to wait for
another i swear to god that's what
that's what i that's what i thought it
was about when i was expecting to hear i
was expecting to hear that story which
to be quite honest with him
wouldn't have necessarily surprised me
um
um anyway uh uh uh
the the two point the logistics i think
representative mullen you sort of
everybody kind of talked about that
representative lakers you talked about
how geographically large some of our
school districts are um and you know you
know a kid may live in the northwest
corner of manchester and his or her
charter school may be in the southwest
so kid lives in the northwest the
charter schools in the southeast corner
we have to find a way to get the child
there there may be no other option other
than having a centralized location just
for logistics for time for money for
cost um i also want to thank
representative mooney she talked about i
think representative lake as who was
mentioned you you mentioned maybe have
um
established guidelines for student
oversight and supervision and things of
that nature and representative mooney
did say
another level of bureaucracy another
level of guidelines for our teachers and
our administrators who are already sort
of burdened with with other
responsibilities so we appreciate that
angle as well too um that's going to
conclude our testimony everybody uh the
conversation sort of brought out a lot
of the concerns that we have so i won't
belabor the point
we're opposed to the bill uh and i'm
happy to take any questions are there
questions for the school boards
association
i got one for you
are we required to tr transport high
school students on a school bus uh thank
you for the question representative no
transportation is for uh grades one
through eight i don't think we've added
kindergarten to that yet technically
that's correct yeah so now the follow-up
to that is that we call school off
because it's uh you know there's no
school that day but the charter school
does have it it's a charter school
high school kid
are we then bound but you know of course
statute says we don't transport we don't
have to transport high school kids but
because we normally do it as a courtesy
would we have to then
run the high school student that's a
good question i don't know if
if i think the previous bill that we
talked about i don't i should have
brought my computer up to pull up the
pertinent statute i believe it says
something along the the same the charter
school children
um or students shall be entitled to the
same
transportation rights i believe it says
as a as a as those in the public school
i've again i should have brought my
computer up with me
we would interpret that as meaning that
you can't exclude the charter school
kids so for example
my understanding some high schools will
charge
a transportation fee for high school
um if you want to ride the bus and
you're a high score you pay 100 bucks a
year or something like that i think i
would without pulling up the statute i
think i would probably interpret that as
meaning
the charter school kid if they paid the
100 hours would also be entitled to the
to the same
so i'm sorry i do have it with me 194
this is the last bill 194 b two
paragraph five
pupils who reside in the school district
in which the charter school is located
shall we be provided transportation to
that school by the district on the same
terms and conditions as provided for
non-chartered public school
uh
shelby i'm sorry pupils who reside in
the school district in which the
chartered public schools located shall
be provided transportation to that
school by the district on the same terms
and conditions as provided for
non-chartered public schools attending
not
in the district and utilizing the same
regular bus schedules and routes that
are provided to people's attending
non-charter public schools so same terms
and conditions i will interpret that
this is that's current law just
everybody be aware that's current law so
if your high school charges a
transportation fee for high school
students and you have a charter school
in your community i would i think i
think i would make the connection that
yes the charter school kids attending
that high school within your district or
your community could also ride the bus
but they'd have to pay that
transportation fee as well
would uh then it be possible or a good
idea for us to utilize the same policy
we have for
high school students going to the ctes
where we reimburse self transportation
at 25 cents per mile
that's that story language right now i
mean i i hadn't i hadn't considered that
representative that might be that might
be one consideration um you know there's
a similar language in rsa believe it's
189 colon 9 that talks about the public
school transporting children who attend
a private school within the district and
i think the language and that this is
terms and conditions i think the i think
the language in 189 talks about the same
rights and privileges as the children
who attend the public school and again
we've interpreted that as if the private
school does not offer
excuse me the private school does offer
transportation on say a saturday the
public school does not have to provide
that and how that works out with with
the school calendar and vacations and
snow days i would presume would be
similar so
you know
that's for private that's for private
schools but i think there's always some
corollary language that
and and hypotheticals that we could use
relative to these last two bills thank
you very much are there further
questions from the committee not saying
thank you very much thank you and that
representative mooney you have two more
you have two more i guess yes yes
so the next bill which we're going to go
into
is hb
1428 relative to the provision of
special education services by charter
do we have any pink cards in that one
you've got some right here okay
i'm going to give these to you just for
a second here going i gotta leave the
room for a little bit here you know
technical rebecca
bergeron you know
that's okay
uh thank you representative we'll open
the hearing
on
and
welcome back to the podium thank you
very much mr chairman and members of the
committee
i am maureen mooney for the record
for the town of merrimack hillsborough
county district number 21. i'm the prime
sponsor and in favor of house bill 1428
and act relative to the provision of
special education services by chartered
the intention
of house bill 1428
is to strengthen
support
and ensure special education services
for children enrolled in chartered
public schools
also my testimony is written and being
distributed at this point
the bill creates three
a new excuse me the bill creates a new
section
in rsa 194 b colon 11 roman 3
which does
the following
and before i get into the following
you'll notice in my written testimony i
have in put in bold
the time frames
that the section
addresses
a in my testimony
at least two weeks
prior
to the start of school
special education plans
shall be finalized
confirmed
and reviewed
between a district
next
if the district fails to provide
services to a chartered public school
student
then within two weeks
of the start of school
the chartered public school
may
hire
or contract
their chosen specialists
to provide
the services
in other words taking that initiative
taking that action
there's a note here in my testimony
the resident district shall continue to
have financial responsibility for the
full cost of the services
and the third part in the new section
if
within the school year
anytime in the school year calendar
a two
week lapse occurs
in special education
services
then also
the chartered public school may hire or
contract their chosen specialists
to provide the services
again with a note
the resident district shall continue to
have financial responsibility for the
full cost of services
just to review the time frames are two
weeks prior to the start of school
two weeks
within
the start of school
and a two weeks lapse anytime within the
special education services
can
not
wait
and cannot find fall behind
house bill 1428 will be a tremendous
advancement in chartered public school
law
to ensure special education services are
this bill
is very important
i cannot emphasize and i am very
passionate about this
services have to be number one provided
number two on time
or the results can be disastrous
no more
if my bill passes
we owe the students
far better
than things i've seen things i'm hearing
about things that come up constantly
i would ask this committee's support of
house bill 1428's passage thank you mr
chair
thank you
oh yes i'm sorry representative nelson
what if the specialists cannot be found
you know they don't exist because
there's
everybody needs them and they they're
not around what happens to the charter
school if they can't find him either
thank you for the question
i would say in that scenario
assuming my bill are you is your
scenario related to the passage of my
bill and that happens okay
um
if that happens your scenario which i
hope it doesn't but it may you're right
there are very specialized people it's
hard to find them
at a bare minimum
you
as a house committee and us as a state
would allow the charter school to at
least start looking start finding and
start the process to locate that person
to provide the services that are needed
and to provide them timely
so yes it may be a scenario like you say
hopefully not but that's possible all
things are
um
it would be unfortunate
you know but perhaps there could be
other alternatives perhaps there could
be a brainstorm meeting to figure out
how to provide the services but my bill
would keep people on a timeline and make
sure that conversation happens sooner
thank you
thank you mr chair thank you represent
when you're taking my question as i read
this it seems to give the charter school
a blank check of sorts in that it
simply says that if during the if the
two-week period if the uh
special education services are provided
then the
sc
the chartered public school may hire
their chosen specialist
uh so i'm concerned about how would you
respond to the concern that that's uh
a blank check and they could uh
spend a million bucks on somebody right
uh thank you for that question
you know um hopefully we won't even get
to the point
of this having to be enacted or you know
having to spend so much money on various
specialists and so forth hopefully that
won't happen
especially if my bill passage passes
then you know it would provide these
guidelines so that hopefully
services will be provided specialists
will be obtained
but i can only think
my experience with charter schools those
behind me
run such a tight ship
with finances and budgeting and the like
i i would be hard-pressed to think any
chartered school would go wild
not spending money in areas they
shouldn't and so forth
i see my bill
only
assisting the situation
providing the guidelines available
and um and hopefully we won't even get
to the point where charter school will
have to contract someone but it may
happen
if the uh sending district don't keep
their end of um
obligations and so on
so i i don't foresee um
your scenario knowing how charter
schools are run in new hampshire
happening anytime soon
thank you
thank you anything further
representative ellison thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question and you may be the wrong person
to answer this but uh i'll ask you
do the the time frames that are
specified in your bill do they apply to
special education plans for students in
well
i guess to answer that i would say my my
focus is the charter is the chartered
public school
and whereas it's been explained earlier
the the public school
the resident public school
pretty much manages the special
education in conjunction with the
chartered school
i tend to think
you wouldn't see a bill like this coming
forward from the public school system
because everything is so accessible
there
in where they're located
i'm not sure
a time frame
is in order in that regard but you're
right i could be the wrong person and
perhaps others can expand on whether or
not such a time frame exists for them
follow-up
thank you
only the question would then be since we
don't really know the answer or we may
get it from someone else
before we were talking about
transportation we talked about parity
parity between charter school students
and transportation public school
students in transportation
i guess my question would be
given your bill if it's enacted will we
have parity between the provision of
special education services to charter
school students and to public school
students i hope so
thank you thank you president woodcut
uh thank you chairman uh kodeli uh
thank you representative for taking my
question i have a couple of them um
i was following up with representative
moffett's question and i understand the
the physical uh con
priority of the charter school how well
they budget their money and and
sometimes how little they have
um that being said however and i'm
looking at section two
it doesn't say what the qualifications
of the person being hired are in order
to say what price you're going to hire
them for i would have the same concern
that if in fact a
a specialist for instance was not
available and you knew someone down the
street i said yep i'll do it for 250 an
hour okay i'll tell you five hours a day
and all of a sudden this public school
building has a non-certified
professional getting paid
a couple thousand dollars by the waiting
times ten days um which which you know
as unfortunately as
uh reverend ellison referred to
sometimes in public education if you
can't get the
specific specialist they're still
waiting and that that's unfair to the
parent i'm not suggesting that but to to
be able to offer this financial piece so
is that that's the first part of my
question is i mean that does that seem a
reasonable understanding for that
section
thank you for the question i wouldn't um
i you know my familiarity with charter
schools which is pretty extensive i've
never known them to contract um someone
who was not qualified for a various
position uh especially when it comes to
special education a lot of times
i plan special education plans will
specifically say
who is needed to perform what and so it
comes sometimes from that guiding
document
so i don't for like representative
scenario over here i don't foresee a
scenario as you're saying either
okay if i may
so if the plane only calls for a one on
one eight and they have the 108 yes um
that does that doesn't mean that they
based on what you're saying the so we're
not looking for an ot person or a pt
person or a speech person they're saying
we need a one-on-one aid
uh to help with child services so but
this allows this charter school to
hire anyone they choose
there's no requirement for professional
certification and pay them what they
choose to do under this bill i
understand you wouldn't do it they may
not do it but it will allow it to happen
yes okay uh and the second one is if i
last one miscarriage
on part a we were talking about the two
weeks to start of school i thought i
heard this morning from the director of
special ed
that
this wouldn't occur
because the
charter school
is not a entity in terms of special ed
they would be uh dealing with the parent
so this if i'm reading number one
correctly you're asking them to finalize
a review between this and the china
public school but they're saying their
connection would be
with the parent because the part the
child school doesn't have a standing as
the lea
yes thank you for the question um
yes but you see the chartered public
school has to work with the sending
district on special education
and i understand i understand that i'm
saying what the what we heard this
morning was that the first thing that
the child the lea has to work with is
the parent i'm not suggesting they
shouldn't work with child school we're
not talking invitations talk about the
way you have it aligned they have to
work with the china public school and
the director of the swine said their
point of contact is the parent
that's all
thank you thank you representative
thank you representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
have you had the opportunity to meet
with the special education director in
merrimack to
discuss how
this
would
happen or
how this would interface with current
practices
have you oops can i have a follow-up um
so
have you met with the special ed
director of any public school system to
talk about how this would work
thank you for the question i've met with
um this is one in my series of you know
coming directly from the chartered
school
i communicate very often with those who
operate charter schools or on boards
foundations and so on
their experiences
in discussing in working with special
education directors where they are
located
comes into play here i don't know
exactly what their opinions are
uh you know the special education
directors at the public schools about
the timeline that i've put forward
my intent was to look after the special
education students who are in the
chartered public schools who sometimes
don't keep to any timeline because
services on the sending district side
thank you see no further questions thank
you for your testimony thank you very
much
thank you mr chairman chairman i'm kim
lavalley from mont vernon and i'm
speaking in support of
hb
1428 i'd like to follow up on a few
areas of conversation with
representative mooney
overall i would say most of the sending
districts are doing their absolute best
to work with the charter schools they're
trying
the problem is
we're in a different location we're in a
different building and it's not as easy
to run down the hall and try to rectify
something we're we're in a different
place
so what we're really trying to do with
this bill is make sure that we have
everything worked out whether they want
to send people to us
that they've approved from their
district or they want to contract they
want us to contract with them for
reimbursement for services which means
we have to hire the appropriate people
with the licenses or certifications that
are required
and we would hire them as our employees
or 1099 them with an agreement through
the sending district we're trying to
make sure that whatever the arrangement
is it's in place for the kids on the
first day of school if we're just
starting these conversations the second
week of school because it's busy for the
districts we get that
but if we're starting conversations the
second or third week of school we may
not see services show up until october
if there's a disagreement on services it
becomes even more challenging so the
goal is to get services in the building
with an agreement with the sending
district that's the goal we don't want
to go out and hire people just because
um
i don't know any charter school that
would go out and hire somebody for some
exorbitant amount of money who wasn't
qualified i've never seen that doesn't
mean i mean doesn't mean it can't happen
but i've never seen it
so
really our goal is to make this work
for the kids that have
services so that we can get them in
place
on time and the kids benefit if they're
missing services
for a month or two or three it has an
impact on their education has an impact
on the school has an impact on their
family and it's just not in their best
interest
i i'll go back to i don't think we're
looking for a blank check by any means
our goal is to coordinate with the
districts that's really what we want and
again most of the districts are really
good about it but there are some
districts where you know you want an mou
you're approaching them for an mou there
was sb 238 yesterday
i know a lot of charter schools want to
work out an mou and it's very difficult
to get a response
i can give you i'm not going to give you
the name of the district if i can tell
you what it's almost a year out and
there's still no mou for the students
so you're hiring people
at their instruction
you're hoping the payment comes through
there's no agreement in place for the
year
but you're trying to do what's right for
the kids and sometimes you have to hire
an extra person because schedules are
tighter when a smaller school less
teachers less classes and so forth
compared to the large district so really
at the end of the day we just want the
kids to get the services in a timely
manner in an agreement with the sending
district it's their responsibility it's
their document we want to work with them
thank you if i could just ask a question
to begin with
the example you just mentioned
there is a district that has been trying
to work out services with the resident
school district for a child in the
charter for a year
but that has not happened and the
charter charters had to
hire
someone to provide the services
called for in the iep is that
what you were indicating
what i'm indicating is the charter
school is providing the services
in the iep for a number of students
without an mou in place
there's a need for an extra special
educator
the mou there's no guarantee i mean you
really want that agreement for a payment
you want to be in agreement on your
payments what you're paying people what
they're reimbursing you so that it's
nice and clean
so it's an mou that's missing services
are there any other questions represent
moffitt
thank you miss sheeran thank you for
taking my question
so when lines nine and ten it refers to
the the chartered public school may hire
or contract with their chosen specialist
now by the school hiring we talking
about an iep team could you clarify a
little bit what we mean by the school
hiring someone i believe the
the goal is to be able to hire if it's a
special educator to hire a special
educator if it's occupational therapy
and we've agreed that the school is
providing it then we can hire one if the
sending district hasn't sent somebody
we
want to be ready with services
and a follow-up yep
thank you
so
i'm one i mentioned before my concern
about a possible blank check scenario
which robertson mooney responded to i'm
also wondering about a search process
i don't want to call it a bid process
but if there is a need to find a
specialist or specialists
i'm just concerned that
with no controls over or limits or
guidance
or structure in terms of spending or
searching
um what if there are like
two possible specialists and one costs
fifty thousand one costs a hundred
thousand i'm just wondering i'm just
concerned about uh quality control so to
speak you're tracking my concern
the bill doesn't really it's fairly
open-ended in those regards i'm just
concerned about blank checks and quality
control and and
bids can you speak to that at all
sure um
as it stands today we try to find the
best person for the job
in a price
range that is compatible with the local
districts
they're the ones who reimburse for
services when there's a contract in
place for that otherwise the districts
are looking for them so i would imagine
it would be
a very similar process we would be
looking for somebody that we know what
they're willing to pay most of the time
we know what those guidelines are and we
would be looking to stay in that range
not trying to hire the most expensive
person
that wouldn't it just doesn't make sense
i'm tracking you thank you thank you for
your question thank you very much are
there further questions representative
porter
thank you mr chair um
thank you for listening
there seems to be some issues here do
you think the issues that
are surfacing
are because the sending district is the
lea
and that perhaps if there was a way that
the state could figure out that the
charter itself would be the lea that
that would improve things for you
i think that's a very tricky question
because for us to be the lea we would
definitely want to see tax dollars
following the student for special
education
you're welcome further questions
i do have one concern
we talk about this two week period of
time that if you if you don't get this
service two weeks prior to start of
school year then you go forward here
what happens when we have
and this is where i found as a school
teacher and school principal for all
those years that we had kids that move
in during the course of the school year
and it takes almost sometimes a month
month and a half two months before
people gear up to get the special
service for that particular student
coming in you're waiting for records to
arrive yes but
you're having to really gear up again
and
do you see this going further than just
the two weeks prior to school would it
be also when students come into the
district or the charter school
and you have a a similar type situation
that's a good question um i would not
want to speak on behalf of
representative mooney typically the
transfers when they come in
the record in my experience anyway the
records are coming
with the student fairly close anyway and
you're able to reach out to the district
but if you were not getting a response
for a few weeks and the child was not
receiving services
yeah i think the charter school needs to
be able to put services in place it's in
the best interest of the student
thank you very much
representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
in your dealings with
i hesitate to
answer for them but
from
what we see in here in general i think
it's a common problem there's a lack of
personnel and for a long time charter
schools were sent people from the
sending district
they would send folks over to do it
charter schools are growing um
ieps are
growing in charter schools and they are
already short staffed i know we've had
several districts tell us we we barely
get by in our own district we can't send
you people so that's fine the child's
not down the hall they're down the road
and
miles over so
the easiest solution for a lot of the
schools lately seems to be to contract
out
people that meet their qualifications
for a certain dollar amount and i think
they're just having a hard time finding
people
and and they're strapped
with other i mean it's it's a thing
across the nation
go ahead thank you very much mr chair
so um
it's a two-part question one um
that being the case why would we think
that the charter schools will have an
easier time finding personnel
and the second part of the question is
have you shared your concerns with the
department of education
we well i have had conversations with
people at the department of ed not
the
ladies here today but other people that
work at the department of ed and charter
schools we've had
general conversations about how
challenging it can be
um
and i forgot you had the first part of
that excuse me the first part was um
why um should we think that the charters
will be able to find people easier than
the public schools
i don't know that we're finding them
easier but we are finding them
slowly but surely we are finding them so
we're able to provide the services as
required in the ieps
yes
can you do it in a two-week turnaround
um
if you sit on the phone long enough in
your computer you'd be amazed what you
can find
it's not always perfect i'm not saying
we're better than the sending districts
but we're smaller
and sometimes it's just reaching out to
your parent community and they know
people as long as they have the
qualifications and it's within the
financial parameters
and background checks of course all the
rest of it but we're able to find them
i know some charter schools you know
like regular traditional schools we all
are missing somebody somewhere at some
point
but we're able to provide the services
you're welcome are there further
in a recent conversation with the
superintendent in the school district in
meyer town we had a conversation about
finding specialists in special education
and one of the questions that came up we
were just talking about the various
disciplines and i was told
that the same position in northern
massachusetts paid a hundred thousand
dollars
and that we didn't have any provision
for getting anywhere near that salary in
that is that
a situation that's statewide i mean i
just don't know it's a naive question
what is your understanding of the
availability of those kinds of
specialists
the availability of a specialist for
any special ed field
they're hard to find but you have to
it's a question of just continuing to
look until you bring them forward i
would imagine if you're competing with
massachusetts in southern new hampshire
that's
that may be more challenging
i can't speak for those schools though
um the one that i one that i'm familiar
with down there has the people in place
no i was just giving that conversation
and not having any data or anything i
was wondering if you had
well we've had people go to
massachusetts they make a lot more money
are there any other questions
not seeing anything thank you very much
thank you very much and for the record
i'm jane bergeron i'm the executive
director for the new hampshire
association of special ed administrators
and i'll keep my uh comments brief
um as we spoke this morning it is the
the responsibility of the local school
district the resident school district
just to oversee
every aspect of special education and
providing a fape which includes ensuring
that
the individuals who are providing
services are licensed credentialed and
hold the appropriate
credentials for the provision of the
services
in review of the bill that we just
listened to we would like to raise a few
questions
the first one is really centered around
the whole issue of two weeks before
school
providing a schedule
ieps are written on a yearly basis so we
know what kinds of services need to be
provided to all kids but as someone
mentioned just a few minutes ago at the
start of the school year you've got kids
moving in you've got kids changing
you've got staff who switch positions
you've got staff who resign you're
hiring people and it can literally be
the day before school that you finalize
a schedule to ensure that the kids are
getting the
all of their services and the quality
that they need so
providing an outside
uh school organization
two weeks before a schedule
that's firm
is not at all realistic so
we would raise some questions around
that piece
the other thing that we would uh bring
to your attention
is around the
two-week lapse for services and again
you you heard uh about the critical
shortages in special education the state
of new hampshire has identified just
about every uh special education
category special ed teachers uh speech
and language
uh our school psychologists our
behavioral specialists we just can't
find them it's not for a lack of trying
um and so to think that in two weeks
that someone could find an individual
make sure that they hold the appropriate
credentials that you've gone through the
background check and that all of those
things could happen outside of the
school district being involved and then
not even knowing how much you're going
to be charged
so we would ask question all of those
questions including um
what the rate setting might be for those
kinds of
situations
let's see what else is in my
so those are our major points we really
feel as though these kinds of things are
really the responsibility of the school
district we find that this would be
an unrealistic expectation to meet
um and would open it up for questions to
all of you
good afternoon mr chair and members of
the committee thank you again for the
opportunity to be here
i am still bob best i'm still that
charter school guy um
very important bill probably the highest
priority one of all the charter school
bills to me and and
my thought and um as before
um with each of these bills
we hear
folks come and talk about adults talking
about how
some of these things are hard or it's
complicated or things are scarce or they
cost a little bit and i'm going to come
back before you every single time and
say
the kids
i don't really
lose sleep over the fact that adults
have
pressures
the kids are the priorities that's why
the schools are there it's to provide
those services that the kids need
and to make sure that they're lined up
and as you heard from representative
mooney
when you fall behind in special ed even
two weeks or three weeks or four weeks
it isn't a shoulder shrug
that might set that student behind for
the entire school year
they may not catch up
from not having those services lined up
that's how important this is a lot of
school districts do figure it out two
weeks ahead of time
the existing statute we heard this
morning in some discussion about how
the lea which is the school district is
responsible for providing the special
education the statute gives them five
different ways to accomplish that five
different ways we talk about blank check
before you can get to a blank check
all of the control resides with the
school district they choose what's in an
iep
they write it up they develop it with
their iep team
and then they choose how they're going
to implement it and in their own school
they do it sometimes with their own
staff and sometimes specialists and at a
charter school here's what the statute
says
the resident district may send its staff
to the chartered public school
or the resident district may contract
with a service provider to provide
services at the charter public school
or
the resident district may provide
services at the residence school
district a resident district school
the resident district may provide the
services at the service provider's
location
and then the last one the resident
district may contract with the chartered
public school to provide these services
five different opportunities to
accomplish this goal which they're
obligated by law to provide on an iep
that they designed
and the only thing that this bill does
is say
if you've failed at all of those things
somebody else can give it a try
someone else can go looking for and and
i know that there's concern about blank
checks and i hear numbers about a fifty
thousand dollar export versus a hundred
thousand dollar expert really we're
talking about special ed teachers that
you build forty five dollars an hour for
um sometimes it's a it's a one-on-one
aid that you build 25 an hour for so
these aren't numbers on the scale of
fifty or a hundred thousand dollars
but their qualifications um and who they
are are set out in the iep
um the 45 and the 25 are special ed
teacher and a paraprofessional
if it's an occupational therapist or a
speech therapist or whatever it is you
can't hire a neurosurgeon for you know a
thousand dollars an hour and slide them
in there and call them an occupational
therapist that's not what they are
and so there really isn't even a blank
check even when you get to the bottom of
all of that
and moreover to the concerns that hey
maybe the school the charter school
would struggle to find people within two
weeks
you know i would love to have more time
you heard from the districts that they
don't even think they can provide two
weeks of advance notice
but what's wrong with allowing the
charter school to try
and at any point even if you if the
school district fails and the charter
school is
call to action by this bill and goes and
looks and finds somebody and says okay
school district i found a special ed
teacher
uh we're gonna do it for pursuant to the
uh
representative mooney bill um and and
charge you for it um if the school
district uh corrects that situation and
steps in and starts to fill their role
then
you know the school district stepped up
and
you know used its statutory obligations
to do so
um and it doesn't always have to look
out into the industry to find some
sometimes the school district has a
special ed teacher or a paraprofessional
sometimes the district has it sometimes
the charter school has it uh sometimes
there's one that's shared between
schools
sometimes the folks are available and
when that happens
there needs to be a response to this
situation where the first day of school
comes
and nothing is set up for an iep that
was written and known for months and
when that happens the current system
puts that burden on the parent we talked
about is there a two-week gap
in other occasions when somebody
transfers into the district and all of
that um right now the statute the the
state of the law is that the parent
would then uh go to the state and file
for a due process hearing to claim that
they are not receiving the free and
appropriate public education and they'd
prove it to the state and then if they
won and they succeeded they would either
get their services or they get what's
called compensatory services sometimes
which
are another troubling aspect of this
because they don't exist either so you
can't find anybody to provide the
compensatory services but to get to that
state hearing and get a result and then
move on
i dare to say if it happened in a month
it would be lightning speed it's
probably more like two or three months
which is a good chunk of the school year
that gets away from you
when you obligate the parents to do it
but you know what happens more often
than that
the charter school
is there with a student in their
building
and
you there's no charter school
administrator or charter school board of
trustees that will tell its staff don't
provide those services
because they have a heart their students
their teachers their school
administrators because they they chose
to be in this field for a reason so the
charter school steps up and provides the
services as uh ms lavallee said with no
contract and no compensation
um
and
the school district
doesn't respond to that at all
why
because the parent
is satisfied there's their child is
getting services parent doesn't care
who's paying for it or who's providing
it
my child's getting services i'm not
going to go ask for a state hearing i'm
not going to go for a due process
hearing
so you end up with a charter school
shouldering the cost of what is the
statute says is the school district's
responsibility
charter schools do everything that they
do on a shoestring budget compared to
other schools and they don't receive any
compensation for providing special
education
even mr chair you talked about
substitutes to cover for iep meetings
all of that money
comes from what charter schools had
intended to spend on
you know their use their their other
programs
and you do it because you have to do it
you do it because you have a heart you
do it because you care about the kids
but it's not the right solution
the law is that the sending school
district is responsible for this the
statute gives them five different ways
to accomplish it all we're saying is
that when that
system goes haywire
the
person left out in the cold the person
that shoulders the bird of that
is not
a 12 year old
it's not the student that's left out in
the cold when something goes wrong that
whatever solution we come up with for
the fact that special education is
really hard the statutes byzantine the
requirements set people up to fail
whatever we think of that system and
those problems which all exist and are
all true
the victim can't be the kid
it can't be the kid that's left out in
the cold
there's got to be another solution and
that's what this bill intends to do
i'll be happy to answer any questions i
don't have anything else that i would
add to my direct testimony thank you
representative moffitt
thank you mr thank you for your
testimony and your friends who've all
testified several times i
applied to you being here and your
intent and your passion and your good
folks and
forgive me for for
circling back to something i've touched
on before
but i've been on a my questions coming
right up i've been on a school board and
i
i see scenarios looking at this language
that scare me and they maybe would never
happen and you and i'm hearing that you
know trust you and that you'll do a good
job line 11 the last part of line 11
line 11 says the child's resident
district
shall continue to have financial
responsibility for the full cost of the
services
and if this becomes statute and nothing
against attorneys most attorneys are
wonderful
they do their job and if if a parent
or a school contracts with whomever
and this
probably will happen there'll be a very
you i've seen it there's going to be
some
huge classes some school districts
uh will be hard pressed
the local public school district
district will be higher priced to
support that but if this goes into law
the the attorneys for whatever family
will say this is the statute the full
cost of the services in some districts
can you reassure us that that uh we're
not we would not be making a mistake i
know we're pepper i'm peppering you but
that's our job
so uh could could you speak to that yeah
absolutely thank you so much for the
question i think it's a great question
it's the one that's on everybody's mind
um and this bill was intended to
be that jolt that is not intended to say
here's going to be a charter school
hiring a bunch of experts at crazy
prices that's not what the bills
intended to do what the bills intended
to do is to say school district
choose one of the five ways in the
statute that you can provide education
and do it
not later not two weeks from now not
some other time you control the iep you
got five different ways to deliver the
service pick one and do it
now how do you get how do you convince
somebody to to follow the law you have a
consequence that's really unpleasant
they lose control over it they don't
like to lose control over it
now is there some thousand dollar an
hour occupational therapist or special
ed teacher honestly no that's the second
part of the answer you talked about
here's the deal every contract every
agreement every obligation that anybody
has as an obligation to act in good
faith and if i went into a courtroom and
i said your honor you should make so and
so school district pay me fifty thousand
dollars for a paraprofessional for you
know 20 minutes three times a week um i
couldn't in good faith uh make that
argument and i am promise you the judge
wouldn't give me the money and so
you know those kinds of things are going
to sort themselves out in the market
will somebody pay 30 an hour for a
paraprofessional instead of 25
because that's what it took to pull some
retired person off the bench and get
them back into the school you bet
and if that's the extra five dollars is
the consequence of this bill
uh money well spent
money well spent
um
so
best i could do for your answer
thank you very much
further questions
thank you all
i don't know if i've got another bill
before you today but if it's if i don't
fare well
well we'll find out
um
we have
one is is the technical assistance from
the doe
rebecca
do you have something you want to
say or
okay why don't you come forward then
please
good afternoon
good afternoon thank you chairman lead
and the committee for allowing me to
speak today um there were a few things
that i wanted to address regarding
the bill
there are some within the bill there are
some phrases that are not defined within
state or federal law when we talk about
a special education plan there is no um
a definition of a special education plan
it would be an individualized education
program
the second piece would be where
the bill speaks to services needed while
special education it provides for a
child with a disability is entitled to
the services set forth in their iep it
is unclear what is meant by services
needed is that the charter school
determining what services would be
needed or is it are we stating that they
would be following the iep
and that those ieps are developed not
just by the school district but by the
iep team which includes the parent so
that is a collaboration between the the
parent the student's parent and the
district to say this is what we have
determined the child needs from the
evaluations that were
completed on the child it is not the
district
creating this and then dictating how it
would be provided it is developed with
the parents and as part of that team
so without clarity for that language it
could be inconsistent and potentially
conflict with the special education
process as defined in the state and
federal law
a few other things when we talk about
the pro
all districts have to go through a
procurement process i hate that word i'm
sorry
have to go through the procurement
process if they are using federal funds
to pay for any of these services so if a
district has decided that to pay for the
speech and language services that we're
providing at these charter schools i
need to use my federal funds
and it becomes a bill that is over ten
thousand dollars they need to go through
pro procurement processes that we have
to approve and say yes you can spend
your federal funds on these dollars if
this bill were to be approved
they would not be getting that approved
through us it would be going through it
would be outside of special education
law both state and federal where we
would be providing authority to the
charter school to expend potentially
federal funds on something that they do
not have the authority to spend those
federal funds on so districts have to be
able to get that approval from us for
um
and then it has been addressed a couple
of times and while i know that
charter schools would do every effort to
make sure that they get the people that
are licensed and certified in the
correct areas they have no no um
authority to say that they have to do
that their rules are very different than
our than
regular public schools so they could be
somebody that does not have the correct
credentials providing a service it could
be somebody who has an elementary
education degree providing special
education services which we would not
allow a regular public school to do so
just the concerns with that as they've
already been raised
as um and i just want to say i testified
yesterday regarding senate bill 238
which is the mou and this bill and then
bill 1141 and then 1014 which we heard
this morning all of these might be
cleared up with
developing a memorandum understanding
this would provide for districts and
charter schools to meet ahead of time to
discuss all of these pieces and come to
an understanding of who's going to get
the speech and language pathologist how
is it going to be paid for how are all
of these things going to be cleared up
so that when you get to that point
you're not saying the child isn't
getting
services and and i do have to say i talk
with
um miss bergeron's group on a regular
basis i talk with other directors on a
regular basis this is not a purposeful
denial of services for those children in
charter schools it's not a purposeful
denial of services in regular schools
right now everyone is having a hard time
finding staff to provide these services
so i i just want us to keep that in mind
as we look at this i want every child to
get every service they need but i also
understand that in in regular public
schools this is also an issue at the
same time representative ellison had
said is is this something that would
provide a different standard for
chartered school students yes it would
because there are times when a regular
public student is not getting the
services they need because they can't
find somebody so this would give a
different standard to charter school
students by providing this language
so while not lit directly related it was
mentioned before
parents still have the right to file a
complaint not necessarily a due process
hearing but they have the right to file
a complaint if their child is not
receiving services they would call the
doe they would speak with natasha
lupiani and again i will go back to she
will reach out to the district but they
can file that complaint because they are
not receiving services and they could be
awarded compensatory services for the
services they have not received that
does not change when they become a
charter school student they still have
thank you very much representative boom
thank you miss jim thank you for taking
the question in normal
circumstances with the local school
district is there any time limit that
they have to start providing services as
this says two weeks
they are saying two weeks we don't have
a time limit but it has to be a
reasonable effort you have to show that
you've been trying if
so if as a scenario if a
parent called and said my child hasn't
had services for three months we would
say to the district show us that you
have been trying to fulfill this role
show us what you've done to try to fill
this role have you even tried to fill
this role have you even tried to provide
these services those are questions that
we ask so you have to show that you're
providing reasonable effort if the
district has done nothing then yes it's
going to be an issue
so follow up so two weeks is not a
reasonable it right now i mean i would
have to ask districts to clarify but
from what i'm hearing no it is not
reasonable
uh i i'd like to just ask you a couple
questions regarding services needed
if in fact you have a student that
transfers in and the parent comes in and
says the iep says i'm going to have
speech pathologists
in other words person with overseas
delivering speech to my child
in conjunction with the iep three times
per week and of course the district that
is short-handed yes there may be a
speech pathologist but the speech
pathologist has
uh meets with that child maybe several
times
uh during the course of maybe uh four
weeks but has a para delivering the
service or the plan
um within the
to identify maybe those articulation or
whatever we're dealing with
is that would that be permissible in
other words we're delivering a service
what the are we meeting the need that's
kind of subjective um
so how would that some a scenario like
this be treated
not providing the same service a parent
wants right so it would depend on what
was agreed upon within the iep if they
in within the iep we list um who
oversees the service and then who
provides the service so if if within the
iep it says that a speech pathologist is
going to provide the service then the
district has not met what was agreed
upon with the in the iep
if it says that the speech pathologist
was going to oversee a speech assistant
providing the service then then yes the
need would have been met but you would
also look at whether the student
continued to make progress you would
look at whether the that the district
made their best effort to provide what
they could
and and what that looks like at the end
of it it's always about progress and
progress towards their goals so while we
might say to them you you know you
should have talked with the parents and
said that you couldn't provide a speech
pathologist and would they agree to a
speech assistant they did do their best
effort to provide services to that child
so they were receiving services and not
receiving nothing
thank you
further questions
yes represent luna
thanks very much mr chair and thanks
very much for joining us this afternoon
providing some clarification on this do
um in your experience do districts do
pay for i guess compensatory services
so t so typically i would say yes they
do everything they can to
avoid paying for compensatory services
however currently i know that there are
many districts who when they are not
able to provide services right now
because they're having difficulty they
are actually tracking services and
voluntarily providing compensatory
services because they know they have not
met the need but they are having those
discussions with parents and saying yes
we're saying that your child needs three
services a week for special education
however i can only do two right now
we're going to track how many we're
missing with you and we're going to come
back to you and look at what the
compensatory services might look like
later on
great thanks so it's so that sounds like
a
working in cooperation with these and
that's not typically what happens but
because of covid that was enacted by
osep to look at compensatory services
ahead of time and we've encouraged
districts to continue to do that so that
they are trying to still trying to meet
that need for students great fantastic
thank you very much thank you
so that concludes the last pink card we
had here on this bill so we will close
this hearing
and we will get ready here to move into
relative to charter public school
eligibility for state school building
aid
14.99
represented on this right i i including
okay
yeah just keep us that right now
melissa
that gets distributed
okay we're going to go ahead
as soon as representative mooney gets to
her chair there
and go ahead with this hearing again
this is 14.99 relative to charter public
school eligibility
for state school building aid
welcome thank you so much mr chairman mr
vice chairman members of the committee
for the record my name is maureen mooney
a state representative from the town of
merrimack that's in hillsborough county
district number 21. i am a prime sponsor
the prime sponsor and supporter of house
bill 1499
an act relative to chartered public
school eligibility for state
school
building aid
given the hour
given your patience and i truly just
want to express my gratitude for
all of your very thoughtful questions
and attention to all of these matters
today i'm going to give my intro and
then look forward to hearing what those
after me have to say so that we can wrap
up in a reasonable time
but please know this is a very important
bill and has been a long time in coming
and in many ways much overdue
house bill 1499 adds chartered public
schools to a series of references within
the statutes for school building aid
eligibility
additionally in section 10 of the bill
there is a repeal
of rsa 194
hyphen b
colon 11
roman 7
which prohibits chartered public schools
from receiving school building aid
school building aid is defined on the
new hampshire department of education's
website as and i quote i have it here in
my written testimony distributed to each
of you but i think this is worth
repeating verbatim from the site
a program authorized by rsa 198 colon 15
hyphen little a
through which the state of new hampshire
provides financial assistance to local
school districts for the construction or
substantial renovation of educational
facilities for grades k through 12.
the passage of house bill 1499
will fully complete this definition by
adding chartered public schools that are
and continue to be
great contributors as k-12 new hampshire
public schools
with that i am going to conclude my
introductory remarks
thank you very much mr chairman
thank you very much are there questions
regarding this bill
to the presenter co-sponsor a sponsor
just a very basic question the ownership
of this building that might be built in
such a way would it rest with the school
or would it rest with the community
thank you for the question the
building
being the chartered school building
that could vary
for example there are charter schools
not saying thank you very much thank you
uh i have some technical questions i'd
like to first ask amy clark is amy oh
for people here amy works with the doe
new hampshire and is in charge of the
mike is your mic on there we go uh for
the record my name is amy clark and i'm
with the department of education i am
the administrator of the school safety
and facility management program and i
the building aid program falls under
that
so i'm here happy to answer any of your
questions if i can
okay the first one i would have in
regard to the 30 to 60 percent of the
does that parallel what we currently
have in law for the all public schools
or districts
uh so you're talking about the building
aid rate yes is that correct so
currently um
representative mooney pointed out a very
good point in this bill is to note is
that building aid
it's not building aid that prohibits uh
charter schools from receiving building
aid it's that repeal that really that
last line in this bill
so in the current building aid law is
the rate of thirty to sixty percent for
public school districts and charter
schools qualify for thirty percent so
again charter schools qualify for thirty
percent building aid but there's a
separate part of the law in rsa 194 that
prohibits them from applying to building
aid
so just keep that in mind but they quote
that currently building aid is 30 for
charter schools district public schools
30 to 60 depending on two factors which
is median family income and equalized
valuation per pupil yes i'm familiar
with that
very much so uh so then the question i
have is that once we release those
applicants that have been approved let's
say on january 15th and that we're
getting ready to go into
the appropriation of dollars from the
town to
facilitate this percentage in all
districts you know let's say the medium
is around 40 percent
um the other 60 it's incumbent upon the
the um
uh the the people that are going to
raise the money locally in the town
there and with the understanding that
the project will uh provide 80 up front
and twenty percent
uh upon completion
and i i'm just imagining it's the same
way in this uh it is correct what do you
mean for charter schools for charter
schools correct
so they would come up with the seventy
percent local locally meaning the
charter school so
where does the charter school go to get
the authorization to raise the money for
the the other part locally from their
whom other words
we have to raise that at town meeting to
you know facilitate the whole thing here
plus what we're getting from the state
where does the uh charter school come up
with the type of dollar that's necessary
for some of these you know expansion
projects yeah that's a good question i
would have to defer to others um how the
charter schools would generate their
money it's just not the state wouldn't
be generating any of it like currently
right now they have to generate 100 of
it but how they do that
i would defer to others behind me that
could speak to how charter schools would
pay for their current construction
project okay thank you other other
questions
of the department for me
oh represent porter
thank you mr chair and thank you this is
something i know very little about so
another under the current situations
that we have
public um local community public schools
own their property it belongs to the
town
most
my understanding is that many if not
most charter schools do not own their
own property
so
i guess i'm i'm wondering how
someone who doesn't own their own
property could
make capital improvements upon it
using this money if they don't own it to
begin with it's like when you rent an
apartment you can paint the walls but
you can't
you know put get a hundred thousand
dollar loan to renovate your kitchen and
then move out so i'm wondering how that
would work for a charter school that
does not own its own building
sure um it's a good point um thank you
for that question there are two pieces
in building aid one is
called building aid and it's for the
construction of a property that they
would own so this would not pertain to
charter schools that lease their
buildings it would be to specifically
you're right not very common but there
are some charter schools that are
growing that are more well established
that are looking for a place to purchase
um and we have some of those that have
purchased there is another arm of
building aid called lease aid which
charter schools are eligible for um and
that is for when they are in a lease
agreement
how would this bill
work for them so for the lease it
doesn't impact they're two separate
programs so a charter school that leases
would apply for lease aid because they
can currently under the current law and
a charter school that owns their own
building
can't apply for lease aid because they
don't own it but they also can't apply
for building aid because the law
prohibits them from applying for
building thank you
representative moffitt
thank you so much mr chair and thank you
for taking my question and i want to
follow up on representative porter's uh
question
um i've received a message from
someone who's fairly familiar with this
area and he says there's approximately
one
charter school that owns its own
property i don't know but to follow up
on representative porter's question if
there's only approximately one
charter school that owns its own
building um
it would seem that this measure
would would almost be moot do you know
if that's true there's only one one i
don't think it's true but you might not
be too far off i think the number is low
but as charter schools grow and as they
have a lot longer longevity they may be
looking to purchase so um but i would
say that
keep in mind that this bill doesn't
increase the cost of building aid it
just allows charter schools to be an
eligible applicant
to building aid so whether it be one
charter school two charter schools that
apply over the course of many years
it will
it will matter to that particular
charter school because they'll be able
to be eligible to apply for building aid
it doesn't increase the amount
of the grant that's available just it's
a competitive grant
so let me
just clarify that building aid is capped
at a certain amount of money and
way more projects we have than the
amount of money for example i have maybe
depending on what the budget is i could
potentially have 40 million dollars
for building aid i already have
applications over 260 million dollars of
those charter schools would just be one
of those eligible people that are
seeking that 40 a piece of that 40
million
i see and that speaks to the recall
provision at the very end um
that was mentioned yes you said a low
number i said approximately one so
gave me a little wiggle room right right
for further questions yes representative
cornell
thank you thank you for taking my
question i'm a little confused if if
they apply for the building aid it's for
a building they already own to improve
or or
um
you know make bigger it's not to build
new construction or is it um both so um
it's a capital improvement so a common
building aid project um there's really
five of them would be to build a brand
new building to substantially renovate a
building again these are buildings they
own substantial renovation putting on an
addition to a building
purchasing
energy efficient equipment that helps
a building and
purchasing land those are the eligible
things so you couldn't building it is
not for small projects
not even a small renovation you couldn't
apply for building aid if you wanted to
redo this room and do the carpet and the
walls that's not a building aid project
however if you wanted to gut the things
down to the studs and rework the walls
that would be a building aid project
yes represent luna
thank you very much sharon thank you
very much ms clark for joining us this
afternoon um
does the department um uh
track the uh the condition and quality
standards of
buildings that are currently occupied by
charter schools
uh we don't uh probably along the same
line well let me just clarify that we
don't in the sense of we don't for
district public school local district
schools either um so we as a
school approval
um
so there's a school approval process at
the department of education that the
department reviews 20
of the
local district schools every year and
therefore it's a five-year cycle 20 five
years it gets so that the department of
education is reviewing a school's
facility
as a school inspection so do they have
their fire inspection report do they
have the health inspection report is
there mold is there are there science
their chemicals being properly labeled
that type of
type of review happens for the local
district schools it also happens for the
charter schools it's just under a
different arm because we follow the
renewal schedule for the charter schools
rather than 20 every year
but it's not a facility condition
assessment of charter schools or local
so it's not like the 3.3 million dollars
we're trying to seek correct it's not
there's no facility condition index
there's no educational sufficiency
standard we don't have a rank um we
don't have a big planning document that
says these are the top schools that we
need to target
okay which would be great other
questions from
tanner
thank you are there uh federal funds and
available for charter schools for
building aid
uh so currently there are no there's the
sr funds and arp funds uh american
rescue yeah arp uh funds they're not
through my program so i'm not
comfortable answering those questions
but those are the covered like just in
general those are the covid relief funds
and they're through a different division
at the department of education um those
but if you're talking about just general
federal funds other than the coveted
relief funds there are no federal funds
available
yes
so i i thought that the uh charter
schools that there was a large grant
from the
and i'm just wondering if that can be
used for building aid uh yeah i believe
um nate greene is here from the
department of education there's a
startup um grant for charter schools and
he's the expert on that so he could
answer those questions if you'd like me
to
would you like date green to come up
nate can come up and while he's coming
up i got a question though to ask you
regarding a little bit of this
um
when we provide these grants to schools
there's a condition that comes down with
it if you walk away from this school in
a period of time what 20 years
you have to pay back the whole loan that
you receive from the state
would this be applicable to this
particular type of grant and
what what kind of assurance are you
going to have that the longevity or the
bonding power or the dollar that they
have will be able to do what we're
expecting as a state to recoup the
dollar we put into it yeah those are
very good questions i'd say there's two
um two things that i think that you
should take a careful look at this bill
again the department of education didn't
um
write this bill but one would be that
penalty section
that you may want to look at to see
if you feel like the state's investment
is protected currently it requires a
local district school to pay back a
hundred percent of their grant if they
leave that project within 20 years
so that's a long-term commitment
it's under the commissioner's discretion
how they whether they're going to waive
any of that so for example we have had
some local district schools close that
we cur that have been within that
20-year period very few but it typically
will happen
it's not happening when the first 10
years usually it's happening like year
18 year 19 and what the department has
done in those cases is that we stopped
paying
building aid if you know building aid
you might know where i'm going with this
but in the old building aid method
let me you just give me a nod if i'm
and we had a 540 million dollar debt
when we started this thing out right and
we're nailing it down and it won't be
done until 2049 or some such year right
so for those that understand we just on
year 18 we stopped paying our 18th year
of payment that's how we handled those
so that penalty would be one thing that
you may want to consider on this bill
and then the other one um is
on page two
line four through six
or
line three through six on page two
and that's that percentage you started
with that question about how much
charter school should be
i would just say that the current
this proposal
kind of leaves that on my desk it says
the state board of education
i know what that means when it's written
in here it leaves that up to me which i
i can do that that's fine but what i
want to point out is the current law
does the formula for local public school
districts so to keep that the same it
might be a recommendation that you that
you all determine
what that rate is going to be if you
decide
to do this right now it says the state
board of education shall develop
criteria to determine the amount that is
closely approximate to what we give
local school districts
again local school districts formula is
current in the in this rsa 195
198.15
and so it might be appropriate for you
all to figure out what that formula is
as well yes that's very complex and
getting alternative stuff too with the
five percent added on and also there's a
lot to this it's just not easy to put in
in a sentence say we got it correct uh
nate green is back up here now can we
follow through with the questions to
nate here
per me
i thought there was a question for nate
first yes
so my question is about the
charter school grant that federal grant
that was received uh substantial
millions of dollars
is that going into building aid
no so it won't part of the conditions of
that particular grant is that it cannot
be used for any capital improvements to
buildings it can't substantially
increase the value of any properties or
facilities that charter schools own
the only building projects that could be
undertaken using the federal charter
school funds are if a charter school is
currently
using a building that is not zoned for
an educational use they can utilize
those federal funds to make whatever
improvements necessary in order to
change the zoning requirements and make
it appropriate for educational use but
anything beyond that would not be
allowable with the federal funds
represent boom did you have a question
yes
thank you
the question is something like like you
started with
charter schools get re-licensed i
believe every five years or if they go
out of business beforehand
so if we give a grant for bill to school
who owns that school
who owns the property it's on in the
local
the town does or the school district
does with the charter school it can be
anywhere so if they
go out of business or they don't get
their license renewed
what happens
that's a good question i i i'll leave
that up for others that know charter
yeah i can speak to that
so charter schools are required to have
a plan for the dissolution of their
assets in the event that the school does
close and that plan has to be signed off
by the state board of education and so
there might be a variety of people that
would be listed as a creditor
depending on where the money or the
assets has come from to that particular
charter school
and then anything that is not explicitly
spelled out within that dissolution plan
those assets revert to the local
resident school district where the
yes go ahead rep san luna so thanks very
much mr chair and just a a follow-up on
representative bones excellent question
um
if um if the local school district
assumes the assets do they also resume
any risk or liability in terms of
the building aid
grant dollars if charter school were to
exit or go out of business or stop
cease operations within the 20-year
period of time
i would need to check back on that
statute but my understanding is that the
local school district does not assume
any of the liabilities they would just
take possession of any assets that have
not already been deemed to somebody else
through that dissolution plan okay so
and follow up on that so so this the the
state could end up holding the bag then
uh
yes but i would want to check back on
are there further questions of the
department of education
if i if i may can i just make one other
comment i had a little bit of time
reading
i just wanna if um this bill does go
through just two things that i would um
consider for an amendment one is on
line seven this is on page one line
seven in line twenty one
both reference an rsa
um both lines reference rsa 198 15 u
through rsa 198 15 w
though that is the section that
calculates the formula for the local
public school districts so if you keep
this you'll also want to reference the
section that gives the rate to the
chartered public schools
and is the criteria that we would use
for the application to get the 200 some
odd points that we have in it right now
that would we use the same formula which
has safety the demographics of the
building all those issues
would that be applied to these and would
they follow through and
have that report also go to school
building authority
correct they would it would be just
making them ineligible they'd follow the
exact same process thank you very much
well thank you very much to the
department uh we do have some more
people that testify on this bill but
that should help us with some of the
questions we might ask others
thank you mr chairman i'm just going i'm
going to be very brief in the interest
of time you've all been very patient
today and had lots of questions about
the bills
i am in support of hv 1499.
and any of my other time i'd like to
allow other people to come up for public
comment
thank you very much thank you
thank you uh and then the other card we
thank you mr chair member the members of
the committee for the opportunity to be
back again i thought it was done but i
miscounted um sorry about that uh very
brief comments um i support uh 14.99 i
think being able to fund the buildings
for charter schools has always been a
really complicated puzzle and one of the
big barriers to getting them going um
in terms of
them getting lease aid in the past that
was certainly a big benefit and
i think that that will continue to be a
benefit for the schools but if you ask
why should so many charter schools lease
their buildings instead of buy their
buildings
it wasn't that long ago single digit
number of years ago
the law actually prevented charter
schools from carrying long-term debt
so they couldn't finance anything for
over five years um and so when that was
in place obviously you don't have
there's no accessibility to buying a
property or owning your own property um
when that law was that way um that's
changed that's been revealed repealed so
that charter schools now can do so um
but obviously bank borrowing is still
very very difficult for them to do so
not many have done it most have been
leased and to that extent it won't have
probably a ton of immediate effect
but part of the reason why um charter
schools don't own their property is
because they've never been eligible for
lease aid and so it's sort of the
catch 22.
um not lease 8 building aid
um
the only other thing that i would add to
that obviously it's a very very
important assistance to the school to
help establish the building the building
is
after the teachers
the biggest cost that you have
in trying to set up a charter school and
you want those buildings and facilities
to be um wholesome and conducive to a
great educational environment
um i think everybody i plan to talk
about who owns the building and how do
we how we know we're protected we're
putting public money into a charter
school building how do we know we're
protected but i think that the folks
that testified before me especially nate
really covered that pretty well the only
thing that i would add to it is that the
statute does require every single
charter school is also a 501c3 charity
which is governed by the attorney
general's office the director of
charitable trust tom donovan supervises
everything that we would do with assets
and the one thing that i can say for
sure is that there isn't any scheme at
all in the plan where the ownership of
that building ends up in private hands
there's just it's it's not possible to
do under all of the various limitations
that are out there so
one way or another
the building will always be dedicated to
some public entity some public public
good or public use
the ones that are out there today that
are leased are more often owned by a
foundation that had to do a lot of
fundraising and god bless them for being
as successful as they have been in doing
that with foundations and fundraising
um but
to the extent that we embrace charter
schools and school choice um is
private funding is it relying on the
charity of individuals the chosen method
to fund public schools
these are public schools for public
school students and i think it's
fantastic that people have come forward
to
purchase buildings and lease them to
charter schools or otherwise fundraise
and be very very philanthropic
that really isn't
the
the way that we ought to approach
funding a
public need
and a public cause
that's all i got thanks thank you very
much any any questions
thank you very much thank you yeah now i
know i'm done this time i promise
yeah we're down to the bottom of 14.99 i
don't have any more pink cards so with
that we're going to close this hearing
and that was the last
oh you had a hand excuse me well come on
up
i think that was last year
yeah
uh thank you mr chairman um
first of all my apology i thought i had
the pink card right but apparently not
so my apology
looks like represent litchfield has it
ah all right here we go i'm bill
phillips
i'm with the national alliance for
public charter schools
um thanks again to the committee for
having me um i see how perilous i can be
uh i almost didn't make it
um
so we are obviously in favor of this
bill uh
i think though i've given you testimony
but i think the way i'm gonna come at
this is i was
writing answers to your questions as
quickly as i could and so let me frame
my testimony to answer as many of your
questions as i can
ma'am i'm sorry i don't know your name
but you you essentially asked a question
of why like why do they need this um
that's how i interpreted your question
when you asked it earlier
um
so here's here's the way i would put it
if if you accept that
creating options for kids and families
through chartering is a policy good if
you accept that uh then you have to face
some of the things that get in the way
of them being able to do that
that's typically lack of access to
startup funds it's buildings it's talent
so obviously today's conversation is
about is about the about the buildings
this issue is particularly relevant
uh once a school gets established and
what i mean by that is typically the
they get their program in place
and they they get their operations under
control and then they start to grow
typically per the terms of their of
their charter
it's once they're getting to a point
where they have to grow
that that the building actually becomes
an issue
and and what i mean by that is it's it's
actually difficult for them to to
finance their building uh primarily
because it's lack of
access to local bonding or local funding
there's two problems with it and this is
the why
this has a programmatic impact um
one of the things i put in my testimony
i think i
gave i cited a study i gave you some
statistics
essentially what it does it hurts their
programming in two ways
you'll see in a lot of cases it makes it
impossible for them to think to do
things like science labs and libraries
and kitchens so they're actually
obviously it's hard to do science
without a science lab in some cases
the other thing it does to them
typically
is it forces them to use their
operational funding to pay for the
building which obviously has an impact
um
part of what i want to get across is if
you agree that we
gotta find ways to get at the building
issue representative mooney god bless
her has
proposed a number of things this session
to try to get at this um she's talked
about the revolving fund we're talking
about building aid and we actually
talked about bonding a little bit a
little bit later
um
building aid is is is one of the better
ways to get at it because typically what
we're talking as opposed to like a
credit enhancement where you just make
the note cheaper building it is you give
them a grant you're actually giving them
money to pay the bill so that's
obviously a very good way to help the
charters
now um
i'm going to try to go through some of
the questions i heard as best i can and
obviously if you have more i'm going to
be happy to answer
something i noticed about the
reimbursement rate um
you picked
or i think ms clark mentioned it was at
30 which i believe is the lowest number
which i think what that means is
typically when you do your building aid
that's for towns that have a better
ability to pay they would obviously get
a lower
amount of aid
i went and looked just so you know who
you'd be serving here
if you look at
children in poverty charters serve about
twice the number of children in poverty
as district schools do it's it's like
seven percent to three and a half
percent so not dramatic numbers but
the point i'm making to you is you're
not the charters are not serving
affluent kids or influent communities
you might
i wish mrs clark was here i was going to
tease her we threw that you know hot
potato at her for hey hear the
department make up a number for us and i
i see she threw it right back at us um
you might want to not have it at 30. if
you if you're interested in doing this
maybe it's the median
um you know which is probably closer to
40. maybe it's the average but
30 is the lowest number and
the kids being server not those kids
um mr chairman i think you asked a
question like how do they
you know how did the bonding be done
um
what they would do is there's you know
if they were doing a construction
project they you know you do a
construction note and it typically gets
taken out by private bonding or you can
just you can actually just bond the
project privately what this would do is
it would make it easier to get private
bonding
or private or private financing
um
the ownership question
so i think i think was mister it was
best was last mr best he was up here
four times i should know his name um
mr best he he's right
on the on the owner on this ownership
issue and what i mean by that is
the reason most of the chart i didn't
know about i didn't know about the legal
prohibition but the reason most of the
charters
are leasing they can't afford to own
their buildings they literally cannot do
the financing for it so this would
actually put some of them in a position
the closure question the
the one thing i think
we might want to check
my experience with
the dissolution process
is a charter is closed
um it
you know they go through a dissolution
process which includes
selling off its assets
my assumption or the way i would
recommend considering this or doing this
you sell off the building
you pay off the bondholder and you pay
off the state which would get at your
question which is like you mentioned
that current process says you've got to
pay to pay the um
the aid back the way i would do it is
the
to basically when you sell the asset pay
pay back the bond holder and pay back
the state
um
representative luna i noticed you asked
a lot of building end questions so i'm
going to assume you were going to ask me
this question so how's this
if i'm wrong you get me
um
selling off the asset
it works great when the asset is
greater than the cost right then
everybody gets paid back and everybody's
happy i think the next question comes up
is what happens when it's less right
and the question i would ask is who's in
front
this is where i i don't have a great
answer for you but i have a couple
solutions
you have to put the bondholder in front
otherwise they won't they won't be able
to finance the building the state has to
go second in terms of who gets who gets
paid
i i think there's um
there's
one of the ways to get at that and this
goes to the federal um
um representative tanner you asked about
the
there is a federal credit enhancement
grant
um
and what you could do is you could
actually apply for that grant and what
you could do is create a loan fund which
would you could use as coverage for
those cases where the
state needs to be needs to be covered
frankly you'd be more competitive for
that grant if we actually had a program
like this to point to
so
um
that's what i have are there any
questions
are there any questions
from the committee
now seeing hands thank you very much
uh we have a card here from matt
southerton
hey good afternoon matt southerton with
the new hampshire alliance for public
charter schools i'll try to make this
brief
oh
sorry about that
uh matt southerton with new hampshire
alliance for public charter schools i'll
try to make this brief i know you've
been here all day
uh so we have three schools that
currently uh own their own buildings
two schools
uh own their own buildings however those
are
actually owned through foundations that
lease the building back to them
one school owns property and they would
like to build a building on that
property
i would like to reiterate that if
charter schools were entered into the
building aid formula or made eligible
for it this would only be eligible for
schools
that own the property and the building
so we're not talking about all the we're
not talking about all the charter
schools that currently lease facilities
and i think that that's an important
part
above all i think this is for
fairness charter schools or public
schools i just believe that they should
be eligible and that's all i had
thank you very much
are there questions for matt
are there any other folks that have
cards they didn't submit to us
then i will close this hearing
thank you very much that takes us to the
bottom of the docket for today so we are
done i i thank everybody for hanging in
there
okay
um yeah we start tomorrow morning at
whoopee
yes
um just a question
uh we didn't have a break this afternoon
so i'd have a chance to get there and
disrupt you uh we'll interrupt you i've
got to notice uh on the
the general court website
there's two on the calendar it says
tomorrow those two we've got that taken
care of where they're the two work
sessions you're talking about that are
yeah i get that but that was some of the
questions yeah a question on the general
quote website i've had three people
contacted me today who are coming
tomorrow it says canceled health
education
they were trying to find the room
and they're coming down specifically for
a bill tomorrow
from carroll county so they want to know
what the k what the status was and
that's what's on the that's what's out
there are they speaking to they're going
to speak to the one at the end 1679
that has not been canceled if you go to
the west this is the whole day this is
the website it cancels the full benefit
of schedule cancelled house education on
the general court website
i understand what you're talking about
the specific one then we'll have to
contact us that's not what's
communicating all we did was cancel two
thank you i wonder how many other
my question is other constituents across
the state who may want to come down on
any of these bills have read that today
and says cancel the houses cancel
that's not the site
no no that's that's you're going to the
for me
well i i've looked at you know
yeah i know don't walk in those wires
you you went to the general court you
went you went judicial
so we pulled you pulled these too well
yeah
are we going to work on that's right i i
i
i called
caitlyn and asked that
um
diana could be here
and so we can look at the ethics thing
we also will be working at that time on
the cte bill with jeff beards yep so
great because we've got about 90 minutes
exactly
and i'd like to yeah
i'll put together a list of things i'll
and he and i chatted for a good half
hour 45 minutes after everything last
night
and then i've also communicated that
with diana and i think that they may
have some language for us okay good yeah
good so maybe we can pull this so i
don't think you have to start working
hard on that because i think we're going
to get it good good and and we don't
need to
they've been getting some stuff up there
like on mondays we had two subcommittees
and they had them both starting at the
same time rather than at ten o'clock and
right yeah
uh and that that's that's
makes me feel a little better yeah
i talked to paul he said call i.t and so
see where we are
education
the bill
1131 it's still up on the web
jeez what's with these people that's on
the calendar that's on the count oh
that's in the counter so that
um
this is this right here yes exactly so
board of education
right
yes that might be an issue there may be
thing is doing
we moved here eight years ago they were
just
you